le premier point sur lequel je
n'insisterai volontiers c'est que cette
pandémie on le sait n'est certainement
pas la dernière que le réchauffement
climatique l'érosion de la biodiversité
vont tous deux provoqué la
multiplication des pandémies du type co
lead et d'autres pandémies la malaria
l'anthrax probablement peut-être même la
grippe espagnole qui pourrait revenir à
la faveur de la fonte du pergélisol en
sibérie et que donc ce qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui je le perçois qu'on m'a pas
comme une espèce de grande répétition
générale
finalement pas si sévère que ça aussi
paradoxal que cela puisse paraître
compte tenu du bilan extrêmement lourd
nous avons en france mais le taux de
létalité finalement du virus est
relativement faible nous pourrions avoir
bien pire et de sorte que je crois que
ça n'aurait aucun sens qu'ont
aujourd'hui on relance un et l'économie
française sans tenir compte des leçons
qu'il faut tirer la pandémie et en
particulier que ce qui nous attend
lié au réchauffement climatique toujours
sur cette question du réchauffement
je voudrais aussi porter à votre
attention le fait que les dernières
simulations qui ont ce qui sont faites
par les climatologues et sur l'impact du
réchauffement climatique sur le
territoire français sont extrêmement
alarmante
donc nous pourrions avoir dès 2040 c'est
à dire quand même après demain matin un
manque de disponibilité d'eau pour
l'agriculture française absolument
dramatique donc ça veut dire que les
sécheresses répétées que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui sont amenés à
une option plus sévère il est quasi
permanente dans les années qui viennent
donc dès 2040 pourrait manquer de
quelque chose comme 40 % de l'eau
disponible aujourd'hui
ce qui pose un problème considérable
pour l'agriculture française
et puis par ailleurs la combinaison des
séquences d'hyperthermie stadire de
calcul et l'humidité de l'atmosphère
dont vous savez que parce qu'on on en a
tous fait l'expérience dans combinaison
peut être extrêmement pénibles pour le
corps humain pour y rendre en tout cas
le sud de l'europe bonne partie
l'espagne l'italie et peut-être même le
sud de la france
invivable avant la fin du siècle c'est à
dire que
on sait d'un point de vue médical que
l'exposition d'un corps humain sans air
conditionné et élire conditionné il
faudra y en entier puisque ça produit
énormément de co2 l'exposition du corps
humain des combinaisons excessif
d'humidité et de chaleur est mortelle au
bout de six ou sept heures l'exposition
est donc que si on continue sur la
trajectoire des émissions de co2 qui est
la nôtre niveau mondial qui est dans le
petit nom pour les spécialistes et le
rcp 8.5 et bien nous avons donc le sud
de l'europe qui devient invivable
commencez pas la seule région du monde à
la totalité du bassin du congo la
totalité les mazouni l'amérique centrale
et l'asie du sud-est deviennent
invivables
ce qui veut dire au passage aussi
probablement des centaines de millions
sinon des milliards dus aux réfugiés
climatiques dans le monde dans la
deuxième moitié de ce siècle
donc c'est et c'est dans cette
perspective là que je me place et comme
mon avis c'est une question de sécurité
nationale pour nous de prendre en compte
ces données là et de prendre aux fins de
saisir l'opportunité delà de ce qu'on a
appelé dans les mines et les médias
sociaux le monde d'après pour nous
préparer à cet environnement
de mon point de vue toujours comme
économiste là la donne est essentiel
c'est que la construction de la zone
euro avec ses faiblesses ses qualités
certes mais aussi ses faiblesses a
accéléré la divergence entre les
économies européennes et favoriser la
désindustrialisation des colonies
françaises
l'industrie ne pèse plus que quelque
chose comme 12% du pib français et on va
de même pour l'italie et alors que la
france et l'italie d'un v7 n'ont pas à
rougir de l'industrie il ya une
vingtaine d'années d'autant que ce que
la pandémie a révélé celle à l'extrême
fragilité des chaînes
d'approvisionnement international à flux
tendu sans stock que nous avons
construites au cours des trois années
qui ont et qu'ils sont à flux tendu
parce que c'est le meilleur moyen de
générer du profit à très court terme
omnis que si vous réalisez des stocks
par exemple les stocks de masques au
hasard évidemment ce sont ces énergies
mobilisées qui ne portent pas de manière
immédiate
donc c'est très grande dépendance de
notre économie s est assis les chaînes
d'approvisionnement fait que nous sommes
très vulnérables et qu'il y aura
d'autres chocs et que le mais on est
nous préparer c'est de relocaliser
partie de notre économie
dans ce contexte la nécessité de
relocaliser ce qui ne veut pas dire la
fin de la globalisation marchande mais
ils ont une option forte pour une
souveraineté économique française est
par ailleurs la nécessité de nous
réindustrialiser mon avis de conjuguer
ces deux phénomènes font que le grand
projet qui nous va être devant nous
c'est celui de la réindustrialisation
verte de l'économie française sur sur la
question de la relocalisation j'insiste
sur un point qui est le grand schéma
macro économique qui a favorisé
considérablement la délocalisation de
l'économie française et pas seulement de
la france évidemment au cours des dix
noms trente dernières années
ce schéma là n'existe plus aujourd'hui
ce schéma a été assez simple nous avions
fait collectivement sur la planète de la
chine
le grand atelier de du monde et la chine
produisait en grande partie et pour les
occidentaux d'aider des produits
industriels à bas coûts grâce à des
salaires de misère chinois et puis les
occidentaux nous nous étions deux fois
voire trois fois bénéficiaire parce que
ça nous permettait d'acheter pour
patcher le produit comme ceci est par
ailleurs l'argent que nous investissions
pour ses achats là donc l'excédent
commercial chinois étaient réinvestis
dans la sphère financière occidentale à
la city ou à londres
en premier lieu vilains via le rachat de
titres et dette publics américains mais
plus largement en alimentant la sphère
financière des excédents commerciaux
issus de centres notre propre argent
nous revenait en tout cas revenait sur
les comptes en banque de ceux qui
bénéficiaient de la rente financière
donc les études au moins deux fois
gagnant les voir trois fois parce que ça
nous a permis aussi en délocalisant
notre industrie en chine de nous donner
bonne conscience sur les émissions de
co2 puisque un appareil sait plus sur
territoire français
nous avions simplement l'exporter à
l'étranger ce schéma là s'est effondré
après 2008 la chine a compris que je ne
pouvais pas faire confiance aux marchés
financiers mais aussi dans toc sont trop
peu régulé et elle a décidé de ne plus
rien investir ses excédents commerciaux
chez nous et de réorienter sa production
industrielle sur son propre bassin
intérieur et sur le bassin du sud est
asiatique
ce qui n'est possible que si évidemment
elle constitue une demande solvable
en gros une classe moyenne chinoise
capable d'absorber
sans laisser dans l'industrie' raison
pour laquelle les salaires chinois sur
la côte est ont augmenté
considérablement au cours des dix
dernières années de sorte que c'est plus
rentable aujourd'hui globalement pour
les industriels européens français en
particulier de se délocaliser en chine
d'ailleurs ils ne font plus une bonne
partie de ceux qui ont des usines en
chine se délocalise maintenant dans le
sud esthétique donc la grande question
c'est le chelsea laitiers qu'aurait-il
d'être longtemps
la deuxième usine du monde après la
chine la réponse est non pour les mêmes
raisons parce que le sud est asiatique
d'abord va être frappé de plein fouet
par les choses climatique et ensuite tu
viens va très certainement la même
logique économique la chine est là du
coup la question qui est posée c'est
serait ce que l'afrique qui serait la
troisième et on pourra rentrer dans ce
débat s'il voulait je n'y crois pas trop
malheureusement pour nos amis africains
même si je pense qu'il ya un enjeu
considérable pour nous à être très
présent auprès de nos voisins africains
dans ce contexte là il n'ya plus
tellement de motifs macroéconomiques
globaux qui pourrait favoriser la
poursuite de la délocalisation en asie
et en chine en particulier
donc du coup je crois que tous les
paramètres sont réunis pour que l'on
mette en oeuvre cette relocalisation
pour être très précis et ensuite passer
rapidement la question et vos réponses
je pense que si on conjugue que cet
impératif la de relocalisation
industrielle en france avec la
transition écologique et avec en
particulier les plans de transition qui
ont été discutés déjà dans le comité des
experts pour un débat national sur la
transition énergétique donc qui avait
été lancée par la ministre mme delphine
batho en 2013 comité auquel j'ai
appartenu qui avait été présidée par
alain grandjean à l'époque nous avions
examiné une dizaine de scénarios de
transition pour la france qui se
distinguer les uns des autres
essentiellement par la nature du mix
énergétique français
en 2035 en gros on dire les choses de
manière un peu brutale par la part du
nucléaire en france en 2035
il n'empêche que quelle que soit
l'option qui est un choix de société un
retenu pour le mix énergétique français
les grandes étapes étaient les mêmes
quel que soit le scénario
donc elles sont connues depuis longtemps
et ce sont les suivantes la première
c'est la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments et je pense que c'est quelque
chose que nous devrions faire maintenant
que tu es tu y est absolument aucun
obstacle dans con
cet immense projet de rénovation
thermique des bâtiments en particulier
public l'état peut le faire demain matin
c'est un projet que j'avais présenté à
l'elysée en 2014 en particulier au
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée à
cette époque c'est parfaitement
finançables je pourrais donner les
chiffres du financement si vous aussi
vous souhaitez et un certain nombre de
banques que nous avions approché en 2014
et puis des entreprises du btp avait
parfaitement compris que c'était un
projet extrêmement intéressant pour
convoler pour elle donc la première le
premier grand chantier de la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
il ya un enjeu en plus symbolique très
fort c'est à dire que vous revitaliser
les centre villes de toutes nos
bourgades puisque vous devez rénové
aussi bien disons la caserne des
pompiers de brive la gaillarde que la
gare de la souterraine ou encore ou
encore le louvre voilà le deuxième grand
chantier c'est la mobilité verte et de
ce point de vue là je ne vois pas de
raisons je vois aucune raison pour
laquelle il faudrait aujourd'hui
autorisé les constructeurs automobiles
français à remettre en ligne de
production des voitures à moteur
thermique
on s'est fait la voiture électrique
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'obstacle
majeur sur la technique sur la batterie
il ya un obtient une question évidemment
d'approvisionnement des mineurs est
notamment nécessaire pour faire des
pâtes riz en particulier le lithium
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on a
suffisamment lithium sur la planète pour
les 50 prochaines années même si tout le
monde se met à produire un tueur
électrique est par ailleurs les normes
européennes produisent une incitation
très forte pour les constructeurs
automobiles à passer la voiture
électrique
donc ce serait du temps perdu de
ressusciter la voiture moteur thermique
aujourd'hui ans la fille est un enjeu
très fort à passer à l'électrique au
tout électrique le plus rapidement
possible le troisième chantier c'est le
plus compliqué c'est pour ça je le nomme
en troisième en dernier lieu c'est la
mondialisation et la relocalisation
verte de l'économie française avec
évidemment des distinction opérée entre
dans tous les secteurs et suivant le
caractère plus ou moins capitalistique
en fait machinique on pourrait dire du
secteur industriel autrement dit plus le
secteur dépend de deux machines ou plus
c'est facile de relocaliser en france
plus il dépend d'une main d'oeuvre bon
marché plus ou moins qualifiés à
l'étranger puis c'est compliqué nous
n'avons pas forcément cette mode
en france vous avez vu le flop de la
question de la du remplacement des
ouvriers saisonniers dans l'agriculture
française des 300000 saisonniers qui
nous manque aujourd'hui par des urbains
français le pas forcément très habitués
à faire de l'agriculture ou de la
permaculture
et donc ces mêmes sujets pour l'ensemble
de la wallonie
la problématique de leur localisation
c'est à dire qu'on a le le véritable
goulet d'étranglement c'est la formation
professionnelle il ya un certain nombre
de ses métiers pour lesquels nous
n'avons pas nous disposons pas de là la
main d'oeuvre qualifiée en france mais
ma réponse est qu'à cela ne tienne et
relancer les chiens à l'apprentissage
cette question est déjà prégnante pour
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments
dans les négociations que j'avais mené
avec l'entrée disons matignon et les
entreprises du btp en 2014 les
entreprises du btp nous disait n'allez
pas trop vite parce que nous n'avons pas
et cohortes d'ouvriers qualifiés pour
faire la rénovation thermique sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
donc leur stratégie c'était lancer
l'opération sur deux régions de l'est
que l'état donné un signal fort qui
veulent faire trois ans après vous aurez
un premier retour d'expérience musée
vitra faire des bêtises au niveau
national et nous entre temps on aura
annoncé les filières d'apprentissage qui
permettront d'avoir un problème de
vous entend plus monsieur giraud
n'entend plus le giro
monsieur giraud n'entend plus là vous
maintenez vous entende a donc j'ai
retiré l'ag retirer l'image d'accor je
continue sa voix ou continuer du coup
uniquement en audio on nous dira
d'accord je vais m'arrêter là pour qu'on
puisse passer aux questions il répondra
donc le véritable goulet d'étranglement
à mon avis c'est la formation
professionnelle
comme je disais c'est déjà une question
pour la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments ça le sera également pour
l'agriculture ce sera également
évidemment pour l'industrie mais je
crois que c'est une formidable
opportunité à la fois pour proposer des
formations professionnelles que nos
jeunes dans mon expérience et qu'ils
n'ont pas du tout envie de reproduire
les métiers qui sont une autre
aujourd'hui et puis c'est une formidable
opportunité de reconversion
professionnelle pour ceux qui se
travaille aujourd'hui dans les secteurs
qui sont piégés par la transition
écologique et qui sont condamnés je
pense particulier en particulier
l'aéronautique
j'en profite pour dire que je pense que
continuer de lancer le projet de
terminal 4 à voici sein de wassit on est
une énorme erreur à la fois stratégiques
politiques économiques dans le contexte
actuel est donc là la question se pose
dès aujourd'hui de fournir une formation
professionnelle en vue d'une
reconversion crois certainement des
salariés français dans un contexte que
nous allons avoir au moins au moins 20 %
du chômage sinon davantage à la famine
voilà je m'arrête là pour répondre à vos
questions
merci beaucoup monsieur geo on peut
peut-être faire une tentative encore
caméra voir si la connexion est alors
attendue inchangée pour l'instant ça va
merci beaucoup pour ces constats cette
analyse un peu peu effrayant par
certains côtés et puis pour vos
propositions pour le moins pour le moins
ambitieuse donc beaucoup de mes
collègues ont demandé la parole s'est
tout de suite la donner à ces rites elle
va inscrire le bel20 menton oui je vous
entends merci monsieur le président
messieurs directeur ainsi pour votre
intervention
je moi je veux tu être revenir sur les
points vous estimez que les aides que
l'état alloue aux entreprises afin de
relancer l'économie devrait être
conditionnée par le respect de
contrepartie environnementale quelle
contrepartie devraient être exigées en
ce sens
ensuite j'ai deux autres questions où ce
n'est que l'état doit investir dans
l'économie verte à quelle hauteur
estimez-vous ses dépenses de l'état
n'est ce pas un risque d'investir alors
que le déficit public a explosé à cause
du confinement et comment financer ces
dépenses alors que l'austérité est de
mise depuis plusieurs années déjà au
sein de l'union européenne et que des
tensions sur la question des dépenses à
mettre en oeuvre pour la relance se font
sentir et enfin ma dernière question
pensez-vous réellement que l'hélicoptère
monétaire serait meilleure solution que
les quantitative easing de la banque
centrale européenne commencée la
devrait-elle être mise en oeuvre en
france quels montants devraient être
alloués au soutien de l'économie réelle
pour que cela fonctionne
je vous remercie jai ho oui mais c'est
beaucoup
on sait sont d'excellents de question je
réponds à tous évidemment ça on en
aurait assez de d'une journée entière
pour discuter de ces questions
je pense que c'est à la main de l'état
l'enjeu c'est de fournir des incitations
pour qu'un certain nombre d'entreprises
prennent des résolutions du côté du
verdissement donc après c'est l'état qui
est choisi et la manade anti fixe les
critères de très bien de dire par
exemple vous engagé pour les cinq
prochaines années à réduire les
émissions de co2 de temps chaque année
moi dans les discussions que j'ai avec
les capitaines d'industrie c'est pas ça
du tout qui les effraie ce qui est
compliqué pour les capitaines
industriels aussi bien du cac 40 que les
pme extrêmement innovante que nous avons
de notre tissu industriel français c'est
le la pénalisation leye labellisation de
la vertu écologique veiller à la
concurrence c'est à dire que si tout le
monde est soumis aux mêmes critères
alors c'est très très intéressant pour
tout le monde
d'où mon intérêt très vertueux si vous
êtes tout seul à devoir être vertueux
vous êtes pénalisé parce que vos petits
camarades ont une faire un doping un
dumping écologique et donc vont rafler
des parts de marché contre vous tout
simplement parce que seront moins
vertueux donc je là on peut on peut
discuter si vous voulez mais enfin c est
complètement à la main de l'état
français je pense que ce qui est
fondamental c'est qu'il ya une
possibilité de vérification
donc pour prendre l'exemple de la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
vous pouvez très bien dire vous avez des
contrats de performance énergétique qui
marche très bien et dont on pourrait
faire une clé pour un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui bénéficient des deux
entreprises du btp qui bénéficieraient
d'aidés publiques mais vous pouvez en
faire autant pour l'ensemble des
entreprises pourvu que l'on ait des des
critères quantitatifs clair pourquoi on
mesurer la profondeur des efforts
réalisés par les entreprises
mon point de vue la question
d'investissement l'état combien et
comment conjuguer ça avec l'explosion de
la dette publique en déficit depuis
évidemment d'année public donc c'est
évidemment les normes sujets politiques
économiques et financiers d'aujourd'hui
combien ça coûterait 50 50 ça dépend
complètement évidemment de la nature du
plan de les re construction écologique
vous mettez en oeuvre pour donner
quelques chiffres un tout petit peu
précis si on prend la question de la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
publics en france hors logement social
c'est-à-dire 10% du bâti français les
quelques gages et frais avec une équipe
d'ingénieurs c'est que ça nous on
pourrait le faire ça nous coûterait
quelque chose comme entre 10 et 15
milliards tous les ans pendant trois ans
et avec ça vous réduisez de 15% les
émissions de co2 de se bâtir ce qui est
insuffisant mais c'est un début et ça
vous créer plus de 500 mille emplois sur
les trois ans un demi million d'emplois
sur les trois ans en france mais ça
n'est qu'un début évidemment après il
faut passer à l'ensemble du bâti et du
bâti français voilà 12 milliards
parfaitement finançables via de la
garantie publique
la garantie publique c'est du hors bilan
donc ça ne grève pas la dette publique
française
donc ça c'est un outil dont je fait la
promotion depuis des années auprès de
l'eau près du ministère auprès de bercy
en disant on devrait utiliser
intelligemment la garantie publique
comme vous le savez on l'a fait en 2008
pour sauver nos banques
2008 on a en quelques jours construit la
société d'un siècle à ce titre française
et que la société de financement de
l'économie française dont la présidence
avait été confiée à michel camdessus et
qui avait fonctionné la manière suivante
cette société est une société de droit
privé mais dans le capital avait été
abondé à hauteur de 40% par l'état 60%
par les banques
c'est la société a levé sur les marchés
financiers avec la garantie publique 70
milliards en un an et reprenne et cet
argent aux banques privées qui nous
rembourser ensuite donc ça parfaitement
joli et ça a permis aux banques
françaises de passer le cap de la saint
sylvestre 2018 en dépit de la tétanie
complète du marché interbancaire liés à
la catastrophe et la faillite de lehman
brothers le 15 septembre et donc mon
point de vue c'est qu'on pourrait très
bien dupliquer ce mécanisme pour
financer tous comptes ou seulement nous
avons actuellement aux besoins
d'aujourd'hui en particulier la
construction écologique française et
l'investissement de l'état c'est la
garantie publique
donc nous venons de céder 300 milliards
de garanties publiques afin de mettre à
disposition 300 milliards de garanties
publiques
on pourrait très bien comment dire si
actualisé partie de cette garantie la
cour financé pour aider en tout cas du
secteur bancaire français a financier
les projets de transition était
évidemment la garantie publique ne
suffira pas donc si on veut faire
davantage là je vais vous donner un
chiffre très très grosse maille pour la
france si on veut faire l'ensemble du
projet dont j'ai parlé un si on choisit
la dgrad scénario sur lesquels nous
avions travaillé en 2013 une 14 et on
essaie de mettre en oeuvre tout de suite
en grand et en large
donc c'est quelque chose comme 50
milliards tous les ans ce n'est pas du
tout négligeable mais en même temps
c'est pas non plus c'est pas non plus 15
% de pib français
évidemment ceci va entrer en collision
avec la question à la dette publique
française
je vous donne mon point de vue sur ce
sur ce set énorme sujet premièrement la
dette publique en france à mon avis
n'est pas l'enjeu macroéconomique majeur
parce que la dette privée est beaucoup
plus importante
nous avons 130 % du pied des dettes
privées 100% que le mossad a augmenté
maintenant cause de la pandémie mais
nous étions en droit 100% du pib' on va
probablement monter à 115 îles à des
prix va également augmenter
donc il ya plus une lettre privée que
des publics en france donc si on pense
ce qui n'est pas mon cas que l'urgence
des urgences c'est de se désendetter il
faut commencer pas assez surpris si on
veut que le secteur privé se désendette
ce qui à mon avis est une priorité
il faut que l'état continue d'investir
et dû dépenser dans l'économie de
manière à éviter la déflation
la déflation c'est cette situation très
paradoxale dans laquelle plus vous
pédalez plus vous enfoncez quand
j'explique un tout petit peu ce que ça
veut dire supposons que l'ensemble des
sénateurs qui nous écouter et moi même
nous constituions l'économie française
et que nous aurions tous et un chiffre
pour simplifier les calculs de tête que
nous ayons tous sens de dette nominale
et que nous essayons tout simultanément
nous et nous désendetter
comment est-ce qu'on se désendette on
vend ses actifs sur le marché alors on
est tous vendeuse donc évidemment le
prix les actifs baisse forcément et
supposons que j'arrive pour ma part à
des réduire le montant nominal de ma
dette de 10 % donc ma des deux passes
290 et si dans le même temps le niveau
général des prix des actifs a baissé de
15% par exemple parce que tout le monde
est vendeur alors en réalité made est
réelle c'est à dire le poids nominal de
mad est déduite l'inflation
mad est réelle a augmenté puisque les
prix ont baissé de 15% tandis que la
dette nominale d'investir lui dit
conscient donc ça veut dire que plus
j'essaie donc des heures d'été avec tout
le monde puisse demande est donc c'est
ce paradoxe cela qui fait que par
exemple la cure d'austérité draconienne
on a infligé à la grèce entre 2010 et
aujourd'hui n'a servi à rien pour ce qui
est du ratio dette publique sur pib le
ratio dette publique sur pied bon grès
est resté sans qu'il y ait encore de
180% niveau très élevé alors que comme
vous le savez on a amputé le qui y ait
au moins 25% et l'économie grecque
en tout cas énormément souffert au cours
des six ou sept premières années de du
plan d'ajustement structurel
le paradoxe est que la dette publique a
baissé mais le pub a baissé à peu près
autant que la dette publique est donc le
ratio est resté identique donc on n'a
absolument pas résolu le problème de la
dette publique
donc ceci pour essayer de vous suggérer
que dans une situation de pointe
déflationniste comme celle sur laquelle
nous sommes en train de glisser ça veut
dire il ya plus de croissance
il y a plus d'inflation il ya beaucoup
de dettes
évidemment le chômage va exploser dans
cette situation-là l'austérité
budgétaire c'est là c'est le pied des
remèdes
c'est un remède à la manière des
médecins de molière c'est à dire ça ça
tue le patient en patient meurt peut
être en bonne santé mais il meurt et par
ailleurs cela n'aide pas à résoudre le
problème du ratio dette publique sur pib
de l'exemple grec en étant la
manifestation la plus la plus
caricaturale amélie donc ça c'est le
deuxième point premier point c'est là
des publics c'est pas le problème majeur
c'est la déprime et d'avoir deuxième
point l'austérité budgétaire ne permet
pas de résoudre le problème de l'aide
est unique dans un contexte
déflationniste comme le nôtre
aujourd'hui
troisième point si vous voulez aider le
secteur privé à se désendetter il faut
que l'état continue lui de dépenser il
est le seul qui peut le faire sans
mourir demain matin alors que le secteur
privé ne peut pas et donc mon point de
vue c'est pas du tout qu'il faut pour
accumuler des dettes de manière
irresponsable c'est que si on veut
procéder de manière intelligente il faut
d'abord que l'état prévu que le pardon
le secteur privé se désendette pour cela
l'état doit continuer de dépenser une
fois que le secteur privé s'est
désendetté et peut réinvestir et vous
savez que nous avons un manque déficit
d'investissements massifs dans
l'économie française depuis une
vingtaine d'années une fois que le
secteur privé désendetter peut de
nouveau investir alors l'état réduit
petit à petit sa dette et pourrait le
faire parce que on aura de nouveau de la
croissance et des revenus et des
recettes fiscales en particulier
voilà c'est ça mon avis le scénario donc
le scénario que qu'à la commission
européenne a en tête et une partie non
camarade version entente est il
exactement contraire si on demande à
l'état de se désendetter s'est
désendetté d'abord et ensuite on prie
pour que le secteur privé puisse à son
tour se désendetter ce qui n'arrivera
pas parce que on en a mis la charrue
avant les boeufs 3
quatrièmement la question de cette
question de la dette publique
à mon avis il va devenir un problème
majeur dans la totalité l'économie
européenne l'italie va probablement
monter à 60 % du public allègrement
atteindre 115 %
on va certainement avoir des moments de
panique delà de la barre des marchés
financiers et donc de mon point de vue
la question de l'annulation au moins
partielle des dettes publiques va se
poser donc comme le comme je le
président il est fait allusion tout à
l'heure je me dis tout de suite vous
allez vous allez m'interroger la tuer
dont je ne fais immédiatement
il est évidemment hors de question
d'annuler dette publique détenus par des
particuliers ou des institutions privées
en revanche une large partie de la dette
publique européenne aujourd'hui détenue
par la banque centrale européenne
et je ne vois aucun obstacle sinon
politico symbolique à l'annulation de la
part des dettes publiques de la zone
euro qui est détenu par la bce la banque
centrale en plus combien ça représente
ça représente 2000 milliards au niveau
de la zone euro 400 milliards pour la
france
est ce que c'est possible techniquement
la réponse est oui il ya aucun obstacle
du point de vue de la comptabilité de la
bce à avoir des fonds propres négatifs
puisque si la bce perdez admettant ses 2
milliards les fonds propres de la bce
qui sont 80 milliards aujourd'hui ce qui
est ridicule passera évidement absorbé
par le choc
donc la bce aurait des fonds propres
négatifs certains hurlent en disant mais
alors c'est la faillite totale de la
zone euro pas vrai du tout la banque et
république des règlements internationaux
la berri la bonne coordination de cette
semaine c'est en anglais qui est basé à
bâle en suisse et qu'elle a donc
centrale des banques centrales a publié
un rapport expliquant qu' il n'y a aucun
obstacle technique et pointu la
comptabilité d'une banque centrale à
avoir des fonds propres négatifs la
réalité économique des fonds propres de
la banque centrale s'est juste de faire
semblant de prétendre que ce sont des
fonds propres de la banque centrale qui
légitime la monnaie qu'elle produit la
banque centrale est l'institution qui
créent de la monnaie
vous comprenez bien que c'est pas les 80
milliards de nos fonds propres de la
banque centrale européenne qui donne du
crédit à l'euro aujourd'hui dans le
monde ce qui donne du crédit à l'euro
c'est la capacité de l'économie
européenne a prospéré qui est sacrément
ils ont fragilisé aujourd'hui à cause de
la pandémie donc le meilleur moyen de
sauver l'euro c'est certainement pas de
conserver 80 milliards de fonds propres
de la bce qui ne servent à rien en fait
qui sont purement symboliques et c'est
au contraire de l'ancien à mon avis un
grand plan de réindustrialisation verte
de la zone euro et pour ça il faut
sacrifier temporairement les fonds
propres de la bce s'il est absolument
pas dramatique et à recapitaliser la bce
dans dix ans une fois qu'on ira mieux et
il n'y a aucun aucun obstacle scandaient
ils alors j'aime lire ta évidemment des
sûr que les faucons raynaud flamands ils
sont farouchement opposés que pour eux
ce sera d'armageddon politique mais je
suis simplement que la france a ici une
proposition à fait au niveau du débat
européen qui à mon avis a beaucoup de
sens donc ça permettrait à la france de
dégager 400 milliards de marges
budgétaires avec lesquels on peut on
peut faire beaucoup évidemment puis la
troisième question m'avait posé je fais
sénateurs c'est quid du quantitative
easing versus l'hélicoptère monnier
comment est ce qu on procéderait le
quantitative easing donc les politiques
d'assouplissement monétaire quantitatif
pour le dire ancien qui l'utilisent en
oeuvre en particulier à partir de 2015
ça consiste essentiellement en un rachat
de titres qui viennent gonfler le bilan
de la banque centrale européenne et qui
permette qui ont permis en particulier
pendant plusieurs années un circuit qui
est l'état par exemple la france fait
procéder à une adjudication du trésor
une banque privée achète le titre d'aidé
public français qu'elle revend
immédiatement à la bce qui s'est engagée
à le faire c'est rassurant pour l'état
français
c'est extrêmement confortable pour la
banque qui évidemment prendre une
commission et donc qu'il ya ce qu'on
appelle un free lunch en anglais donc un
repas gratuit
en fait elle fait un profit sans risque
qu'elle est certaine que la bestiole on
achètera son titre donc c'est
extrêmement bénéfique pour la banque
mais ça ne nous ça ne nous délivre pas
du problème puisque si encore de la
dette
donc ça veut dire que la dette française
continue d'augmenter et donc si vous
voulez absolument réduire la dette
française il faut pas faire du
quantitative easing c'est pas l'objet le
quantitative easing en plus et mon point
de vue ne résout pas le problème de fond
qui est que nous avons fait l'erreur
dans le traité de maastricht et en
france depuis la fin des années 70
de faire dépendre le financement public
de l'état par des marchés pour des
marchés financiers comme si les marchés
financiers étaient suffisamment sage et
avait suffisamment disons l'intérêt
général ont vu pour pouvoir dicter à
l'état française qui va faire dans ses
dépenses publiques ce qui me semble une
hérésie les points de vue politiques et
économiques je n'ai aucune aucun
argument analytique même du point de vue
de l'économie la plus orthodoxe est le
plus favorable aux marchés financiers
pour m'expliquer des marchés financiers
serait suffisamment efficient pour avoir
quelques mots à dire intelligent sur la
politique publique en fait
et puis s'il vous aura pas échappé qu'il
favorise toujours le même type de
politiques publiques
donc de mon point de vue en amont de ce
les questions de financement il ya un
énorme sujet qui est la reconstitution
de ce qu'on avait appelé les circuits
les trésors de bloch lainé qui on
favorise les qui ont rendu possible la
reconstruction de la france après la
prière pendant les trente glorieuses
c'est à dire la l'état emprunte
directement à sa banque centrale à taux
nul et d'une cette manière roule la
dette qui la veille avait lui-même ce
qui lui permet de consulter les marchés
financiers alors donc les camps le
quantitative easing ne permet pas de
reconstituer le circuit trésor les en
fait les juristes allemands de la cour
de karlsruhe s'en sont bien rendu compte
raison pour laquelle ils ont toléré le
bout des lèvres du quantitative easing
depuis depuis cinq ans le quantitative
easing donc ne permet pas de résoudre le
problème et la dette que si encore de
l'ayguette fait toujours dépendre le
financement de l'état français des
marchés financiers puisque ça passe par
la case banque est par exemple vous
aurez remarqué que la bce à racheter
davantage de titres confortable titres
français pour l'instant les titres
allemands que lui titres italiens alors
que l'italie aurait bien plus besoin
d'un quantitative easing musclé que la
france
donc en fait ça c'est lié au fait que
les marchés financiers tarifie price
comme on dit en dans le jargon des
marchés financiers price la dette
italienne beaucoup plus mal que la que
la d'être enceinte donc non je ne
délivre pas du joug des marchés
financiers et sont simplement disons un
extraordinaire cadeaux faits aux banques
pour la pl mettre du sien financer
sans risque par contraste la ville
côtière monnaie c'est tout à fait autre
chose c'est la création monétaire qui
n'est pas de la dette
il est donc ça ça que ça consisterait
par exemple à demander à la banque
centrale européenne de d'abonder la
banque européenne d'investissement et la
baby pour que celles ci puissent
financiers en france d'échecs
prenez les choses de manière triviale
soit trop entreprises en particulier au
pmu à mon avis qui sont très mal logées
dans la situation actuelle en france
soit aux ménages donc comme vous le
savez les états unis l'ont fait
l'allemagne l'a fait en partie pour un
certain nombre de destinataires
quelle serait la différence majeure la
différence majeure c'est que
l'hélicoptère au bonnet s'il est de
l'amener actifs
ce n'est pas de la monnaie dette mais ce
n'est pas une bête ce qu'il faut juste
que je rappelle qu est-ce qu il est bien
connu évidemment c'est que lorsque vous
accorder un crédit vont créer de la
monnaie et donc des banques privées
chaque fois qu'ils accordent un crédit
écrit la manie cette monnaie circule
dans l'économie en fonction mais ce qui
est fait avec cet argent
et puis à cette monnaie revient tôt ou
tard dans le bilan de la banque qu'il a
émises au moment de la du remboursement
de la dette
donc au moment du remboursement de la
dette vous vous détruisez la monnaie ce
qui est tout à fait normal donc notre
économie fonctionne en permanence de
cette nana là c'est comme le sang qui a
pris dans l'organisme il explicité par
le choeur et puis il revient dans le
coeur le choeur ces bilans bancaires et
donc la raison pour laquelle la quantité
de monnaie en circulation augmente en
permanence et que en une économie qui
croît et qui fonctionne normalement
chaque jour vous avez plus de nouveaux
crédits le remboursement des anciens
donc au total la quantité de monnaie
augmente plus ou moins rapidement en
fonction de la vitalité l'écologie donc
si vous faites du quantitative easing
vous injectez la monnaie dans l'économie
mais c'est une monnaie dette qui tout ou
tard va revenir dans le bilan de la
banque centrale ou en tout cas des
banques de second rang des banques
privées qui ont utilisé la monnaie
banque centrale pour accorder des
crédits dans les conneries si vous
faites de l'hélicoptère menacé de la
banque d'abonnés actifs qui restera dans
l'économie qui ne re qui ne réintégrera
pas le bilan de la banque centrale
européenne deuxième grande différence et
j'aurais dû le souligner est déjà dense
que j'ai rappelé à propos du
quantitative easing le quantitative
easing à comme je disais essentiellement
de bénéficier au secteur bancaire
et après peut bénéficier à l'économie
réelle a été très peu difficile et les
banques qui ont bénéficié de la manne
monétaire de la banque centrale
européenne l'ong essentiellement
utilisés pour financer la bulle
financière sur les marchés financiers
établis l'immobilier et un certain
nombre de projets industriels pointent
donc ça rejoint les normes question deux
pour les dires de la sagesse du crédit
bancaire et qui laissent beaucoup à
désirer à mon avis depuis une vingtaine
d'années pourquoi parce que les banques
pour faire des profits à très long terme
préfère financer disons des opérations
financières fort effet de levier sur les
marchés plutôt que l'économie réelle qui
est faible et qui importe peu de
rendement involontaire donc
l'hélicoptère venait si vous la flèche
paix du côté des pme en difficulté et du
côté des ménages
vous êtes sûr que c'est l'argent qui
arrive dans la poche de l'économie
réelle alors que le quantitative easing
dans la baie aucune garantie et
l'expérience des cinq dernières années
montre que c'est plutôt raté de ceux
conduits là donc voilà si salée des
grandes différences à mon avis entre
d'un côté un financement via du
quantitative easing
de l'autre un financement via
l'hélicoptère mali évidemment le
mécanisme l'ico père monnaie on vous
auriez la bce qui crée quelques
milliards par exemple la destination
dhabi puis les redistribuer aux pays par
pays demande un vrai débat politique sur
combien par pays
quels secteurs mais de toutes les
manières à mon avis il faut bien qu'on
ait un jour lowe's utile de débat
politique au sein de l'union européenne
puisque ce qui nous tue aider mon point
de vue c'est le caractère unijambiste de
la construction en peine
nous avons fait un marché unique nous
n'avons pas d'instances politiques en
pleine en face du marché unique
autrement dit et pour les équipes de
l'ordre dans les années 90 en était
parfaitement consciente
vous savez que ce qu'elle espérait c'est
que on apprend à marcher dans ton banc
donc avec une jambe c'est pas possible
la deuxième jambe c'est la jambe
politique et de paris l'équipe de
l'homme années 90 ce serait que c'était
que la jambe politique ou la construire
et lyon à force de nous casser la figure
avec une seule jambe
malheureusement là
disons les forces centrifuges de
divergences entre les économies du nord
et du sud
créer de manière endogène parlera au feq
font que c'est plus en plus compliqué
mais je vois pas d'autre issue si on
veut sauver le projet européen que
d'avoir un vrai dialogue politique
publique aujourd'hui au niveau européen
pour lancer ce genre d'opération donc je
suis assez favorable à une politique d
hélicoptères menaient en tout cas bien
davantage qu'une politique de
quantitative easing
maintenant je rajoute encore un mot je
vous laisse apparaître que dix mois je
suis trop long je suis pas convaincu
qu'il fallait tout faire en même temps
c'est à dire si on annule une partie de
la dette publique détenue par la bce
on n'a pas forcément besoin de faire
l'écho car les conditions que chaque
état utilise intelligemment la marge
budgétaire qui lui est ainsi accordée si
on n'annule pas la dette publique de la
bce
je suis très merci beaucoup le giro
alors j'ai beaucoup de demandes de
parole nous pouvons peut-être regrouper
les questions je prends par un groupe de
trois questions et je veux donner la
parole tout de suite à 22,6 drac
merci monsieur le président bonjour je
perds collègue monsieur giraud merci de
votre présence vous avez signé une note
pour l'institut rousseau sur la
reconstruction écologique
dans celle ci vous appelez à se donner
les moyens de bâtir une économie
circulaire digne de ce nom je vous cite
vous mythique et déjà pour une économie
plus circulaire avant même cette crise
sanitaire que nous traversons le
coronavirus semble pourtant faire
revenir le plastique sur le devant de la
scène donnant à tort parfois un
sentiment de protection aux
consommateurs
et en plus avec la chute du prix du
pétrole même le plastique recyclé risque
d'être moins privilégiés donc moi
j'avais une première série de questions
rapides
ne craignez vous pas comme certains
d'ailleurs un retour du plastique en
force dans quelle mesure l'économie
circulaire doit être central dans cette
relance vert et bien sûr quelle peut
être la place de la loi du 10 février
relative à la lutte contre le gaspillage
et à l'économie circulaire sur cette
relance bien sûr vous avez d'ailleurs et
j'ai une autre série de questions
parfaitement illustrer l'intérêt de
saclay d'abord
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
avant même vous avez dit de s'intéresser
à l'art eu l'occaz il re localisation
pardon de l'industrie autres les
avantages écologiques vous y voyez au
circuit économique et social puisque ce
sont des emplois non délocalisables
comme vous l'avez suggéré il faut donc
lancer la formation professionnelle aux
métiers de demain
cette nécessité montre effectivement que
la mobilisation de tous les pans de la
société est nécessaire en réalité pour
qu'on arrive à avoir le rebond tant
attendu vous avez déjà répondu sur les
volets financier et sur un certain
nombre d'économies d'énergie que l'on
peut attendre en les chiffrant mais
j'avais une dernière question qu'elle
doive être en réalité les priorités en
matière de formation professionnelle
pour justement nous puissions répondre à
cette rénovation énergétique en masse
merci je donnais la question si vous le
voulez bien
il paye un peu comme sa boîte au bout de
3 2
donc monsieur longtemps de la presse
quand monsieur jacques un monsieur
bonjour monsieur le président merci
merci d'abord de regrouper les questions
parce que une partie de ma question qui
a été posée par marta vous citera
monsieur le président mais mes chers
collègues monsieur giraud je tiens à
vous remercier ou ce giro pour vos
propos de ce matin propos qui ne sont
très précieux je suis avec intérêt votre
avis vos propositions qui ont le mérite
de ne pas tomber dans une vision des
protistes mais bien de proposer une
économie post croissance
je partage ainsi votre position les
chantiers de la reconstruction doivent
se faire autour de la rénovation du bâti
de la mobilité verte du fret ferroviaire
de l'aménagement des territoires en
faveur des circuits agroécologiques
cours ainsi que d'une relocalisation
d'une partie notre industrie c'est ce
moment vos liens que vous appelez de vos
voeux vous dit également que d'une part
la politique monétaire menée par la bce
ne peut pas tout assumer
car celle ci sert davantage des membres
que l'économie réelle c'est ce que
voulait dire et que d'autre part il
faudrait annuler des dettes publiques
détenues par la bce pour financer la
transition écologique et relancer
l'emploi
quelle mesure une telle proposition
peut-elle être crédible alors que la
cour suprême allemande remet déjà en
cause le problème anti crise de la bce
dans quelle mesure également estimé vous
qu'en l'absence d'une telle politique
notre continent fait face à un risque de
dépression dans les années qui viennent
la cause du confinement
pour ma part je suis en faveur d'un prix
plancher au sein du marché européen du
carbone ainsi que la mise en place d'une
taxe carbone aux frontières
mais je suis également convaincu de la
nécessité de faciliter les
investissements verts en permettant aux
membres de les extraire du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance
la remise en cause de la discipline
budgétaire budgétaire part donc pour est
elle selon vous conduire une telle
position
enfin pensez vous à l'instar de
christian gollier que nous dénigrent il
pour une europe des carbonées soit
forcément condamnés je vous remercie
merci le surjeu monsieur monsieur
jacques un là il est là il faut qu'il
appuie son micro c'est monsieur jacques
1 n'est pas la gelée de la part d'un
madame tocqueville telle ville oui merci
bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur je
suis particulièrement intéressé par des
propos que vous avez tenus concernant la
relocalisation de l'industrialisation et
actuellement je travaille avec mon
collègue sur la sécurité alimentaire ou
nous évoquons bien évidemment la
relocalisation de la production le
développement des circuits courts et des
circuits de proximité ce qui est pas
tout à fait la même chose
et évidemment produire la louant
concerne donc j'aimerais avoir votre
votre point de vue sur cet aspect d'une
relocalisation très ciblé d'autres pas
la présidente de la commission
européenne a rappelé avec insistance que
les importants plans de relance qui
seront nécessaires en europe pour sortir
de la récession économique
devons prendre en compte la dimension
climatique donc elle est tout à fait en
adéquation avec ce que nous avait exposé
donc tout le monde semble d'accord et
j'ai envie de dire y'a plus qu'à et ce
matin nous entendons malheureusement que
l'écran portes françaises continuent
d'investir dans les énergies fossiles
excusez moi qu'en pensez vous est ce que
il ne faudrait pas passer du stade de
l'incitation au stade de la sanction et
enfin j'ai une dernière question la
convention citoyenne pour le climat a
rédigé pour que le fabrique 2020 une
contribution pour la sortie de crise
évidemment en appelant à une
relocalisation des différents secteurs
stratégiques qu'en pensez vous est un
élément important semble de remettre le
citoyen au coeur de la réflexion
cela aussi est évoqué à de nombreuses
reprises pensez-vous effectivement que
les citoyens doivent aussi s'emparer
n'est pas seulement être entendu par les
grands acteurs économiques et par l'état
pour faire avancer donc cette réflexion
vers une relance verte
je vous remercie sinon un peu gris donc
le sujet au jeu vous propose de répondre
aux questions 22,6 drac le selon joe et
madame tout le film merci beaucoup je
vais forcément être plus rapide et
lapidaire unis il ya beaucoup de
questions sur la question du plastique
oui je crains comme vous madame la
sénatrice que le plastique reviennent à
l'ordre du jour ce serait une très
mauvaise opération d'autant que le
pétrole même si le prix du pétrole est
très bas aujourd'hui le prix du pétrole
ne restera pas aussi bas qu'il est pour
des tas de raisons la première c'est que
nous allons vers une raréfaction de la
la disponibilité du pétrole dans les
années qui viennent ça c'est l'énorme
sujet vous connaissez sûrement du pic
d'extraction du pétrole savais qu'au
niveau mondial on a atteint déjà le pic
avec tt conventionnelles d'extraction en
2006 niveau mondial autour de 98
millions de barils jour d'énormes
questions à plusieurs milliards
aujourd'hui qui est posée aux ingénieurs
pétroliers c'est qu'au camp sera le pic
d'extraction avec les techniques non
conventionnelles c'est à dire notamment
la fracturation hydraulique de la roche
vous savez sûrement qu'il ya deux
tribunes du côté des âges ayant peut
être relié à une tribu qui nous dit
qu'en 2025 une deuxième qui nous dit
pour 2060 6 et 2025
ça veut dire que le prix du pétrole est
appelée dans les années et très
rapidement dans les années qui viennent
à devenir très élevé en tout cas il y
aura certainement très très forte
volatilité des prix du pétrole c'est
certain parce que si vous avez de
nouveau un choc pétrolier avec une
augmentation rapide du prix du pétrole
vous avez nécessairement un affaissement
très rapide de l'économie mondiale
puisque pour l'instant nous continuons
de dépendre énormément du pétrole il cet
affaissement fait la demande s'effondre
et donc le prix du pétrole baissent de
nouveau et continue de faire des
montagnes russes comme ça avait été le
cas d'ailleurs en 2008 donc refaire
dépendre une partie notre économie du
pétrole c'est la pire des mauvaises
idées qu'on puisse avoir aujourd'hui à
mon avis ce qui est un enjeu pas ce bon
pronostic mais pour l'ensemble de notre
économie française vous savez qui
essentiellement le déficit de la balance
commerciale en france dans ce difficile
des 70 milliards qu est-ce qui ont
uniquement des importations de pétrole
donc voilà je crains j'ai la même
crainte que vous et j'espère qu'on va
résister à cette tentation à l'est nord
est au contraire ça doit être un enjeu
de politique publique aujourd'hui lui
souveraineté nationale que de réduire
notre dépendance alcatraz l'économie
circulaire vous le savez certainement
moi j'y suis très favorable
je pense que c'est un changement on
pourrait dire d'une civilisation qu'il
faut opérer
nous avons fait la révolution
industrielle et plus d'un siècle avec
l'idée d'une économie linéaires c'est à
dire que on prélève aux produits ça fait
du pipe disons et du bien-être pour les
citoyens et si tout est en fait non en
fait on produit également des déchets en
fait une économie c'est un grand
métabolisme comme métabolisme humain qui
est produit des déchets à chaque fois
que vous lui et qu'il ingère dillon
d'énergie de matières il fait pas
simplement du travail
ces déchets leur pouvoir être recyclé
évidemment c'est l'énorme question par
exemple
d'une parce que vous savez que nous
allons avoir des pictes extraction de
minerai également donc mes travaux
montrent avec un géophysicien o'neal et
vidal qu' on pourrait avoir un pic
l'extraction du cuivre au niveau mondial
en 2060
le cuivre à des applications
industrielles absolument mastin partout
être est assez peu substituables est
absolument décisif pour les
infrastructures les yeux aux énergies
renouvelables dont il faut une façon un
usage très intelligente du crime c'est
donc à un moment clé puis même nom même
pas faire la transition énergétique
en fait tous ces minerais et partant
dans les petits bijoux comme ceci donc
il ya un enjeu considérable en fait à
passer à une culture industrielle disons
du low tech en conservant le high tech
toupet contre le secteur je pense en
particulier au secteur médical
mais pour toute une série d'autres
secteurs on n'a absolument pas besoin
d'avoir ses prouesses technologiques que
sont ces objets là dont l'énorme défaut
et qui sont très difficiles à recycler
tout cas le recyclage et demande
beaucoup d'énergie et d'argent donc là
vous voyez que c'est l'ensemble disons
du de la culture industrielle kilomètres
qu'il faut réinventer pour pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre effectivement une
économie circulaire pas simplement c'est
déjà beaucoup dans le dans le monde
agricole mais aussi dans le monde
l'industrie et la loi du 10 février à
mon avis doivent être absolument
maintenue et renforcée pour aller dans
cette direction sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments dont je me
réjouis nous soyons d'accord sur ce
point
peut-être que ce que je peux dire à ce
sujet c'est que de mon point de vue et
ça donnera peut-être un élément de
réponse à d'autres questions qui m'ont
été posées
elle s'inscrit à mon avis dans un projet
plus vaste de réaménagement du
territoire français
si on veut faire des économies d'énergie
au niveau urbain
disons-le à l'optimisation urbaine et
les relativement clair en fait il nous
faut des petits centres urbains
circulaire pourquoi circulaire s'était
dessinée mathématiques parce que ça vous
c'est là c'est la forme géométrique lala
qui vous permet d'avoir la la surface la
plus faible
à périmètre donné et donc il nous faut
les petits centres urbains circulaire
avait beaucoup de transports publics à
l'intérieur du centre urbain plus de
voitures ou simplement des voitures
électriques conception absolument besoin
de la polyculture autour de chaque
centre urbain pour qu'on arrête cette
folie d'avoir uniquement du blé dans la
beauce uniquement du ler normes anti
uniquement de la viande dans le limousin
de la polyculture avec du fret
ferroviaire qui achemine la nourriture
dans la gare et donc auprès des centres
commerciaux à proximité des gares donc
ceci en fait est connue depuis un bon
moment j'ai souvenir en 2015 en 2014
2015 pardon d'avoir envie à l'elysée un
fonds autrichien qui voulaient investir
5 milliards dans les centres commerciaux
français à proximité dégâts dans les
villes moyennes et qui parce que c'est
une grosse opération on voulait le feu
vert politique de du gouvernement de
l'époque et bon qui a été très mal reçue
mais ça signifie signaler le fait que
dans la sphère financière cette forme de
investisseurs ont très bien compris que
si ça doit venir ça veut dire notamment
que ça sonne le glas de la grande
distribution et des supermarchés qui
sont à quelques kilomètres du
centre-ville auquel on ne peut avoir
accès convoite sûrs qu'ils font
exactement le contraire du schéma que je
viens de décrire évidemment ça suppose
aussi une réhabilitation du maillage du
réseau ferroviaire extrêmement dense que
nous avions en 1945 et que
malheureusement nous avons en grande
partie détricoter alors que par exemple
la belgique l'allemagne en partie la
suisse ne l'ont pas détricoter
mais c'est une très bonne nouvelle que
ça crée énormément d'emplois et sa
remontée une bonne partie du territoire
français
ça va nous permettre de nous livrer un
petit jeu que nous raffolons dont nous
aimons beaucoup qui est nous bagarrer
sur la question de savoir s'il faut que
le train passe plutôt à la souterraine
ou plutôt à dun-le-palestel mais c'est
le prix à payer pour qu'on puisse y est
à mon avis il mener à bien ce projet
dans la formation professionnelle vous
m'interrogez sur les secteurs qu'il faut
privilégier
ça me semble assez évident que
l'agriculture parce que la situation
actuelle démontre doit être une des
priorités
l'autre c'est des secteurs industriels
sur lesquels nous avons des industries
prête à soient localisés et pour
lesquels nous manquons de main d'oeuvre
manoeuvre qualifiée après il faut
regarder dans le détail les secteurs
industriels
je peux pas le faire là maintenant
d'antan qui m'est imparti réaménagement
du territoire voilà je crois que j'en ai
dit un mot la cour suprême les
casseroles l'offre dans le bras de fer
qui en ce moment entre la cour de
justice de l'union européenne et elle
accorde 15 rounds je pense qu'il faut il
faut je voudrais vous livrer mon analyse
là dessus les deux ont tort et les deux
ont raison
au sens où moi je donne raison et c'est
ce que fait le alain supiot apprécié
anthropologue du droit et 4e a raison de
rappeler la fragilité la position de la
cour de justice européenne qui prétend
se donner une autorité juridique
supérieure aux droits constitutionnels
que vous savez le compte que cette
sandale en allemagne c'est l'équivalent
de la constitution chez nous et donc ce
que fait la kul classe rôle c'est juste
de rappeler les décisions de la cour de
justice européenne ont demandé la
jurisprudence de la constitution plaît
ne s'impose pas et ne prévaut pas sûr
droit constitutionnel et je vois pas
comment nous français on pourrait ne pas
être d'accord avec la cour de karlsruhe
donc si je sais bien que le conseil
constitutionnel suis en traînant des
pieds la position des quatre fois sur
cette question parce que le conseil
constitutionnel ait lui-même en bagarre
chez nous avec la cour de cassation qui
elle est complètement inféodées au
conduit la cour de justice européenne
mais je crois que alors je suis pas
constitutionnaliste ne suis pas juriste
lui comme bis mais je vois pas tellement
comment comme citoyen français je
pourrais ne pas donner raison à la fois
des classes roule sur cette question là
je pense que c'est aussi une question de
souveraineté politique de droit
constitutionnel français jusqu'à plus
ample informé s'impose prêts vont en
tout cas sur le sur la jurisprudence de
la cour de justice
il n'en demeure pas moins que par
ailleurs la cause justice à un point qui
est pas d'excusés mois n'ont cessé
contraire ce que je veux souligner c'est
que par ailleurs la cour de justice base
la totalité de ses décisions sur un
concept qui économique évident qui est
celui la concurrence pure et parfaite
qui a servi en fait de deux comment dire
d'éléments fondateur du parti du projet
rockhal à mon avis à tort évidemment
comme vous le savez le dogme de la dg
concurrence à la commission européenne
eba mais heureusement du parti nos
collègues à merci c'est tout ce qui nuit
à la concurrence pure et parfaite dans
une économie était mal venu
du point de vue de l'analyse économique
la concurrence pure et parfaite ça
n'existe pas on est toujours dans une
situation marché en présence de
confiance en parfaite confiance en
partie au niveau politique avec
évidemment toujours des alliances plus
ou moins dissimulées entre les acteurs
industriels qui seront en concurrence
sur le marché et donc par exemple
interdire une politique industrielle
volontariste comme celle que nous avons
vue pendant la reconstruction de la
france
après la guerre mondiale au motif que ça
créerait des distorsions sectorielle qui
nuirait à la concurrence pure et
parfaite
c'est une hérésie économique à mon avis
donc leurs proches l'autre reproche que
je ferais à la conduite justice
européenne c'est de base et l'ensemble
de ces décisions jurisprudentielles sur
un concept qui gêne au pertinents de
l'onu
alors après évidemment j'ai moi aussi
dire que la cour de karlsruhe joue aussi
une partition qui est extrêmement
néfaste pour le projet européen puisque
en gros et continuelle de penser par
ailleurs que l'ensemble de l'europe
devrait être allemand ou allemandes
alors que je crois qu'il faut absolument
que l'allemagne aujourd'hui deviennent
est repris et donc d'envoyer mon point
de vue il est que personne à tous les
maux raison tout le monde a tort dans
cette affaire et que donc le suivant le
l'objet exact de la discussion sur le
bras de fer entre la cour de justice
européenne et de la couronne 15 trous et
voilà je crois qu'il faut avoir un du
néant si ce qu'ils espèrent n'est pas
une manière de noyer le poisson dans
l'eau dans ce débat mon point de vue
allemand étant que il faut cesser de
mettre la concurrence parfaite comme
objectif sacro-saint puisqu'il et les
vides de sens et surtout on a besoin
d'une politique industrielle
volontariste ce qui suppose des options
sectorielle à privilégier voilà il c'est
pas grave du tout bon pour la confiance
premièrement et deuxièmement le droit
constitutionnel français s'impose sur la
jurisprudence de 4 troisièmement il
n'empêche qu'il faut absolument qu'il
faut qu'on allemand fasse des
concessions pour sauver projet européen
parce que je crains fort que à l'issue
de cette pandémie nos amis italiens
espagnols ne supporte plus du tout des
diktats allemands comme vous le savez
les négociations qui ont eu lieu
quelques semaines au conseil de l'europe
pour débloquer quelques malheureux
centaines de milliards niveau européen
ont été extrêmement violente
donc il ya des insultes qui ont été
proférées par certains ministres
italiens espagnols à l'égard de l'un des
représentants allemands leary flamand et
je vois pas comment il pourrait se
calmer dans les années qui viennent
donc je pense qu'il ya un danger
colossal parce que nos voisins allemands
fasse des concessions pour la terre dans
l'intérêt et du projet européen sur la
taxe carbone je suis également très
favorable comme vous le savez peut-être
un gie fait partie de la commission
stiglitz qui a fait
17e 2018 pendant un duo 17,1 sous
l'égide de la banque mondiale et l
initiative à l'époque de la la ministre
ségolène royal donc voilà j'y suis très
favorable il à la taxe carbone à
d'immenses avantages sur le marché des
droits à polluer qui comme vous le savez
ne fonctionne pas en europe depuis les
années de grands avantages de la taxe
c'est que ça permet symphonie des
recettes fiscales pour l'état qu'il peut
réutiliser pour financer un chèque
énergie à destination des ménages qui
sont pénalisés par l'augmentation des
prix du pétrole à la pompe
et c'est évidemment ce que nous aurions
dû faire de mon point de vue pour nous
éviter une année de protestation des
gels et jaune et la détermination de la
détérioration du climat social telle
qu'on l'a connue alors extraire les
investissements verts du pacte de
stabilité j'y suis extrêmement favorable
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet sur lequel
je m'exprime peu en ce moment mais j'ai
depuis plusieurs années proposé ça
également d'une manière plus générale si
vous voulez il ya un paradoxe quand même
dans la comptabilité nationale qui est
que on compte sur un pied d'égalité les
dépenses d'investissement de long terme
avec les dépenses courantes dans une
entreprise on fait jamais ce type de
simulation
on distingue très soigneusement
d'amortissement des dépenses de long
terme avec les dépenses courantes dans
le dans la comptabilité nationale
peut-être qu'en - l'année
conçu par eurostat à luxembourg au
mélange des deux et donc c'est une
bêtise qui nous pénalise le niveau 2 1
des investissements publics de long
terme
donc évidemment je suis très favorable
au fait qu'on retire n'est pas de
stabilité tous les investissements verts
de long terme dont nous avons absolument
besoin et je pense que ce serait du bon
sens comptable en fait que le faire ça
pour ce qui concerne les la sécurité
alimentaire donc jeunes on sache et
sénateurs tocqueville quoi je suis très
favorable également enfin je sais c'est
un enjeu absolument centrale bien sûr je
ne pense pas sauf si vous n'êtes plus un
formule moi je ne pense pas que nous
souffrions dans les mois qui viennent
d'une rupture des chaînes
d'approvisionnement alimentaire en
france en revanche c'est évidemment un
enjeu absolument central crise
humanitaire
en inde et en afrique subsaharienne ce
qui ne veut pas dire que dans l'avenir
une soyons jobs en protéger donc je
crois aussi que c'est un enjeu de
sécurité nationale sur les grandes
banques françaises
vous avez souligné qu'elle a juste titre
qu'elle continue de prêter aux énergies
fossiles
vous savez qu'un rapport de la dodge &
cox tram paru il ya quelques mois qui
montre que pour un euro investi dans les
énergies renouvelables et les banques
françaises investi 7 euros dans les
énergies fossiles et vous parler de
sanctions bon j'y suis aussi favorable
mais je pense qu'il faut pas oui je suis
d'accord avec vous les incitations
patients ça suffit pas c'est ça c'est
manifeste aujourd'hui mais je crois
qu'il faut comprendre la logique
financière qui est sous jacente à cette
attitude c'est que la plupart des
grandes banques françaises qui ont
financier la révolution industrielle
française est en tout cas la
construction de la france au cours du
20e siècle ont de leur bilan des
milliards d'actifs qui dépend désirable
[Musique]
voilà donc on dans leurs bilans des
centaines de milliards d'actifs qui
dépendent des hydrocarbures fossiles
elles savent très bien que si on procède
à une transition écologique massive
rappelé in volontaire dans les années
qui viennent
elles sont en faillite parce que si vous
déclarez demain matin que le charbon est
un actif échoué à dallas est en anglais
dont la valeur à l'économique nuls alors
sa cruelle ça creuse des trous noirs
dans les bilans des banques
mais même histoire si vous le faites
pour le pour le pétrole pour le gaz donc
en fait donc donc savent que une vraie
transition écologique signifie leur mort
quasi instantanée d'où le jeu de dupes
auquel se livrent nos banques à mon avis
de faire semblant de ces convertis à 3
smic logique alors qu'elles ne peuvent
pas un trafic mans le faire le meilleur
exemple étant les fameuses obligations
vertes
lili kwhy bon sinon à peu près rien
devait en vérité qui sont absolument
aussi brûlé verte que n'importe quelle
obligation
aujourd'hui sur le marché donc le bon on
peut sanctionner les banques évidemment
mais ça résout pas non plus de problème
je pense qu'il faut comprendre donc
elles ont dans leurs bilans des actifs
qui en réalité sont déjà des actifs
échoué si on croit à la transition
écologique
et donc la vraie question aujourd'hui
une explication à plusieurs centaines de
milliards si et comment les débarrasser
de ses actifs donc une option qui est la
même que celle qu'on a essayé de mettre
en oeuvre qui aujourd'hui est remise à
l'ordre du jour par certains animaux il
consiste à mettre en place une banque de
défaisance bad bank qui récupèrerait les
actifs échoué de nos banques de manière
à les en débarrasser alors après tout la
grande question est donc il est une
question politique c'est à quelles
conditions vous faites ça c'est à dire
est ce que l'état reprend une part dans
le capital des banques pour pouvoir
contrôler d' usage qu'elles font de
leurs fonds propres et la liberté
qu'elles vont retrouver une fois qu'on
est dedans à débarrasser des actifs
pourris parce que 100 des actifs liés à
notre labeur faustine qu'elles
détiennent dans leurs bilans si on fait
aucune contrepartie à une telle
opération ça veut dire juste qu'une fois
de plus on privatise les pertes on
privatise les profits on socialise les
pertes que la puissance publique que ce
soit l'état français et l'union
européenne ue récupère les actifs
pourris que les guerres les banques ont
gardé dans leurs clients ont pu ordonner
crise des banques
les tribuns évidemment du citoyen et
donc je suis pas favorable à la
construction du bac dingue
parmi les faisant ce sans contrepartie
mais je souligne j'attire l'attention
sur le fait que je ne vois pas tellement
comment on pourrait faire l'économie de
la mise en place d'un objet
institutionnelle de cette nature
conditionnait évidemment à l'obligation
faite aux banques de une politique de
crédit beaucoup plus virtuelle du côté
des énergies renouvelables il n'est pas
impossible que ça passe par la
nationalisation des banques
et je crois que c'est ça qu'ils
craignent le plus c'est bien qu'elle ne
le elle se dit certainement que une
vraie transition écologique volontariste
et massive signifier à terme leur
faillite ou la matérialisation et puis à
une dernière question que je crois sur
la convention citoyenne de citoyens
sinon revenir au coeur de la réflexion
j'y suis également très favorable je
pense que pour ma part ceux ci pointe
est un enjeux civilisationnels majeur
qui est la prise en compte des communs
donc dans certains d'entre vous ont
peut-être entendu déjà parlé si on l'est
pour pour le game manière très rapide
les juristes ce qu'en fait ça bien du
droit cette affaire-là et les
économistes après eux ont pris
l'habitude de penser le monde à travers
deux catégories de biens de ressources
et de services qui sont les biens privés
d'un côté
qui serait réservé à la sphère marchande
et puis les biens publics qui serait
réservé à disons une bureaucratie et
public qui ne manquera si l'état en
réalité déjà dans droit romain vous
aviez d'autres catégories de biens et en
particulier ce qu'on appelait la res
comme disent les biens communs et
appartiennent à tous mais dont personne
n'est en particulier propriétaire
mais non nous avons tous la
responsabilité et je crois que ce qu'on
a ce don fait l'expérience aujourd'hui
avec la pandémie fait que la santé est
un bien commun c'est même un comme un
mondial au sens où la santé d'une
famille d'une riche famille chinoise
avoine qui mangent du porc bovin le soir
concernat totalité l'humanité nous ne
pouvons pas nous désintéresser de la
santé de nos voisins et même de
d'humains qui sont très élevés ce qui
veut dire que la santé est un commun ça
peut pas être un bien privé si vous
privatiser la santé voulu donner un coup
si vous donnez un coup ça veut dire que
les plus modestes ne pourront pas
s'acquitter de ce coup donc ça veut dire
qu'ils vont récupérer le virus il donc
ils vont contaminer tout le monde mais
monsieur qui aurait les moyens de se
protéger
donc je ne pouvais pas traumatiser
l'amour peut-être l'attisé les biens
communs voulait détruire vous pouvez pas
non plus espérer qu'il y ait un état
mondial qui gère la question de la santé
les deux candidats pour laurent soulier
lâcher aujourd'hui les 30 août au castro
fils je pense à la chine aux états unis
je suis pas du tout favorable parce
qu'on est en état mondial bon ça serait
toute élection donc
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut les
institutions capables de prendre en
charge un certain nombre de ressources
comme une transversale que ce soit au
niveau international au niveau local
alors quelles sont ses institutions ses
les institutions qui prennent en charge
les communs et qui ne sont ni privé ni
public et dont mon expérience c'est que
la plupart du temps ce sont les
associons hybride qui oblige tout le
monde à s'asseoir autour de la table des
négociations et discuter l'exemple moniz
en favori si lady ndiaye jackson et
qu'il était décédé chérif qui est un
objet qui était l'hybride étrange pour
nos catégories qui a été élaboré par des
médecins français de mémoire celle des
anciens de maintien du monde ont
peut-être du médecin sans frontières je
veux pas du tout
peut-être les deux et il ya une
quinzaine d'années dont le siège est à
genève et qui a réuni autour de la table
des états la puissance publique dès le
secteur privé est en acier tic et des
ong
donc la société civile et donc aussi les
citoyens pour faire quoi pour produire
du médicament des thérapies à
destination des maladies négligées par
secteur privé parce qu'il n'y a pas de
demande solvable pour ces courses les
pathologies l'exemple l'hépatite c en
egypte est vendu et donc la thérapie
contre l'hépatite c
les vendus aujourd'hui par dirait contre
300 à 400 $ en egypte alors qu'elle vaut
2 à 3000 euros en europe
donc comment est ce qu'on a réussi cet
exploit en créant les conditions d'un
dialogue intelligent entre les trois
parties prenantes que sont l'état la
société civile et les secteurs plus et
mon point de vue c'est que c'est ça le
grand jeu disons de civilisation qui est
devant nous
par delà un investissement massif de
l'état qui à mon avis est absolument
nécessaire mais l'état tout seul peut
pas tout faire donc il faut évidemment
le secteur privé qui les montent dans le
bateau est aussi là chelsea civile et
des citoyens parce qu'il ya toute une
série de questions qu'ils peuvent être
résolus effectivement que par les
citoyens qui sont sur le terrain alors
dit andy est un exemple c'est mon
exemple favoris parce que c'est un
exemple internationale qui prouve qu'on
peut même le faire au niveau
international je pense que la question
de la santé par exemple devrait
aujourd'hui nous amener à réfléchir à un
objet institutionnel qui peut pas être
juste le ms puisqu'on a vu que même si
ça ne suffit pas ça marche pas bien mais
qui peuvent pas être simplement les
états donc il faut autre chose et donc
dans là on a besoin d'une créativité
institutionnels dont à mon avis nous
sommes tout à fait capables puisqu'on
était capable de faire avec des indiens
au niveau local sur le territoire
français par exemple il ya une
créativité incroyable que vous
connaissez sûrement autant que moi sinon
davantage un exemple très simple c'est
les des modules et des monnaies locales
les monnaies complémentaires qui
fleurissent un peu partout aujourd'hui
en france qui sont un moyen pour des
communautés de citoyens de se
réapproprier l'instrument ne l'était il
est j'y suis très favorable
évidemment ça demande d'être un tout
petit peu régulé et l'accompagner voilà
mais on pourrait très bien imaginer par
exemple que dans certaines collectivités
territoriales avec bien évidemment
l'accord de la puissance publique on
autorise des monnaies locales qui
fonctionne bien il n'en existe
à traverser le circuit complet de la
monnaie c'est à dire qu' une partie des
salaires des fonctionnaires locaux
seraient payés dans cette monnaie locale
et une partie des impôts acquittés par
les citoyens d'impôts locaux serait
acquittée dans cette monnaie donc le son
que cette manière qu'elle ferait le
circuit complet en passant par le par le
bilan de l'état en tout cas la
collectivité locale il ya des monnaies
locales qui permettent des volumes des
transactions absolument colossaux alors
pas tellement en france on est on est
plutôt en retard sur cette question mais
en sardaigne par exemple kardex totalise
l'équivalent d'un milliard de
transactions
hollande à milliards d'euros transaction
chaque année donc ça devient
significatif
ceux qui sont évidemment très opposé un
développement résolu des monnaies
locales sont les banques ils m'ont privé
qui voient ça d'un très bon oeil puisque
ça les priverait du monopole de la
création dans les terres dans cette
jouissent aujourd'hui puisque defacto en
fait la construction de l'euro à revenu
à privatiser la monnaie la bce n'ayant
pas de compte à rendre auprès d'une
instance publique politique européenne
démocratiquement élu sur le la politique
précise monétaire que la mettent en
oeuvre
de sorte que en réalité c'est vrai
interlocuteur soit 150 ans quand vous
avez une banque dont la taille de bilan
est égal au pays des français en cette
bande va discuter à francfort avec habib
sylla avec plaisir tant qu' état rentier
merci beaucoup je ne sais pas si le
cieux jacquin et connectée maintenant
chacun n'est toujours pas connecté donc
je vais donner la parole à monsieur gold
et merci président bonjour monsieur zéro
montré l'ampleur de la crise est certes
inédite mais nous avons pourtant déjà
connu ces dernières années des alertes
sérieuses qui aurait dû nous permettre
d'anticiper une crise plus sévère
alors les constats que nous pouvons
faire est celui d'un pays comme beaucoup
un mal préparés à ce que nous traversons
aujourd'hui alors que d'autres pays je
citais taiwan par exemple sans faire
face de manière plus efficace
il est bien entendu toujours hasardeux
de comparer des pays mais qu'est ce qui
explique selon vous la préparation de la
france
et quelle leçon que l'on peut tirer des
stratégies mises en place dans les pays
qui arrivent mieux contenir la
propagation d'épidémies
et puis par ailleurs vous appelez de vos
voeux en réponse à cette crise une
relocalisation de notre économie et le
lancement d'une réindustrialisation
verte
la période que nous traversons semble
être en effet une opportunité à saisir
pour prendre ce chemin mais force est de
constater que les raisons qui ont mené à
quarante années de délocalisation des
productions industrielles et de certains
services sont toujours là quand le lobby
au lobby de la mondialisation même si
cette crise révèle la fragilité extrême
modélisation ils sont toujours présents
eux aussi est pour l'heure toujours
puissante
pensez vous que depuis sion malgré tout
espérer demain une autonomie et
souveraineté économique stratégique
notamment je pense à celui de la santé
en termes de production de médicaments
et matériel par exemple est ce qu'on
peut est ce qu'on peut imaginer
finalement une vague de nationalisations
de prises de participations publiques
dans les domaines stratégiques même si
vous avez déjà un peu et qu'il est une
réponse à cette question je vous
remercie
merci monsieur chevalier
oui merci monsieur le président le sujet
oh merci pour votre exposé vous avez
déjà répandu un certain nombre de
questions dans le cadre de votre
présentation de plans de relance verte
de l'économie moi je voudrais simplement
savoir comment aujourd'hui sont perçus
aux propositions par le gouvernement
français et autres points et vous en
avez vous parlé sur sur le fait de
d'augmenter l'investissement public donc
dans un état comme le nôtre qui est déjà
largement endettés comment ce type de
proposition peut être perçue par des
citoyens français inquiets sur le niveau
d'endettement avec la crainte de d'un
appauvrissement généralisé
autre question quel est vrai
travailler sur la nécessité sur l'après
crise d'aborder la question du temps de
travail dans la société française et la
meilleure gestion de l'argent public est
un autre axe de réflexion sur un autre
projet le politique
j'aurais revenir aussi sur le l'écart
entre la position la situation de la
france et la situation de l'allemagne et
donc ses politiques de relance avec le
couple franco allemand dans une
situation très différente et politique
très éloignées quel avenir européenne
dans ce contexte et dernier point
puisque vous l'avez évoqué sur les
enjeux autour du continent africain
j'aimerais que vous puissiez développer
votre analyse sur le futur du continent
africain si vous en avez parlé sans sans
développer merci monsieur merci ce
chevalier je vais donner la parole à
madame filleul oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur giraud accepteriez
vous de revenir dans le détail sur votre
plan de rénovation des bâtiments publics
en effet c'est une idée extrêmement
séduisant je crois que très modestement
beaucoup d'entre nous ont essayé de la
porte et localement ou même
nationalement sans beaucoup de deux
succès et donc vous avez identifié vous
même des freins tout d'abord l'absence
de volonté politique la question
également de la formation
professionnelle est-ce que vous pouvez
nous aider à dégager d'autres freins à
voir clair sur la difficulté à mettre en
oeuvre un tel plan et répondre aussi à
mon interrogation sur la question des
collectivités territoriales est ce que
vous ne pensez pas que c'est aussi
ils se sont tous les acteurs principaux
qui doivent être mobilisés plus
particulièrement pour mettre en oeuvre
un tel plan de rénovation des bâtiments
publics
voilà je vous remercie beaucoup merci
beaucoup je ne mets apparent la mieux
même bonne foi et après on répondre à
ces tas de questions là encore une fois
voilà moi est ce que vous entendez oui
oui bon je me suis par exemple jamais
chaque collègue bonjour monsieur giraud
à la crise la crise sanitaire donc de
2020 l'une des plus graves crises en
temps de paix que nous ayons connue elle
a révélé donc les défaillances et vous
l'aviez bien rappeler de notre modèle de
développement donc porté par une
mondialisation libérale ainsi que notre
grande dépendance économique trop grande
à l'égard de d'autres pays
elle a également révélé les fractures
sociales territoriales sur fond de
montée des inégalités et d'un
persistance du chômage donc des profonds
changements sont nécessaires et vous
avez donné des pistes pour construire le
monde d'après le monde nouveau qui donc
a besoin d'une transformation importante
moi je voulais vous interrogez vous y
avait un peu répandu sur la thématique
des communs qui permet de mon point de
vue précisément de repenser nos modes de
production consommation et
d'organisation de nos sociétés pour
réinventer donc un mode du vivre
ensemble soutenable socialement inclusif
démocratiquement participatif et
préservant la valeur et la richesse
créée par le commun donc moi je je je je
voulais vous demander même si vous
l'avez dit comment inscrire le commandât
notre société et je voulais peu plus
particulièrement vous interroger sur une
proposition de loi que nous venons de
déposer avec mes collègues au sénat pour
justement inscrire le commun dans la
constitution a et donc vous demander ce
que vous en pensez à savoir subordonner
la défense de la liberté d'entreprendre
et de la propriété privée à la défense
de l'intérêt général
donc son inscription dans la
constitution je vous remercie pour votre
réponse
merci beaucoup monsieur g aux jeux vous
propose de
répondre à ces quatre questions et
ensuite il nous restera un groupe de
quatre sénateurs dont je vais essayer de
faire alors la préparation ou taiwan de
mon point de vue sachant que je ne suis
pas hésité l'épidémiologue donc comme
vous le savez sûrement le sénateur
giraud avec qui je crois pas avoir
dénoncé la création des prusse
l'établissement prévention et de réponse
aux urgences sanitaires qui devait
coordonner une réponse intelligente et
efficace à des pandémies de ce type là
et puis nous avons entre temps divisé
par 10 ou budget décrue ce qui n'avait
plus les moyens d'opérer de sorte que
nous n'avons on n'avait même pas dix ans
dans l'administration française de plans
de réponse coordonnée autant que je
sache des mythes ce type là par
contraste taiwan la corée du sud
singapour le vietnam avait des plans
parfaitement rodé depuis avec toutes les
alertes ont eu lieu précédemment h5n1 à
chânes d'un tic et donc on ce qu'ils ont
fait très très concrètement c'est qu'il
y avait un dépistage massif dès le début
de la ddb la pandémie en chine un autre
pays qui a très bien réagi c'est
l'islande
c'est évidemment mais quand même ici on
a commencé à dépister les personnes qui
arrivaient sur l'île un mois avant le
premier cas positif donc au vide en
islande donc c'est à dire qu'elle était
tout à fait capable de d'endiguer la
pandémie à condition de dépister
suffisamment tôt aux frontières et pour
que le virus avec notre territoire il
faut bien qu'ils aient un porteur de
merlin qui arrive sur territoire
et si vous dépister en théorie
évidemment vous bloquer complètement la
pandémie ce qui n'arrive jamais mais en
tout cas vous limiter considérablement
son extension ce qui a permis donc au
pays
extrême orientaux des jt confinement et
l'extraordinaire casse économique et
social qui est la vôtre
le deuxième facteur bien entendu c'est
disons la faiblesse sans l'avis du psy
du secteur hospitalier français et
public
comme vous savez il y avait en moyenne
deux fois plus de lits de soins
intensifs en allemagne par tête
d'habitant que qu'en france alors même
si je sais bien que nos agences de santé
régional ont fait des prouesses nos
médecins ont fait du crawl a multiplié
par deux
je crois que c'était trois fois plus en
allemagne au départ on a multiplié par 2
de notre côté le nombre de lits dont on
a attrapé un tout petit peu notre retard
mais malheureusement c'était très
insuffisant donc il ya aussi un énorme
enjeu de construction d'un système
hospitalier performances skis et ne veut
pas dire du tout à mon avis la
privatisation du système hospitalier je
suis certain qu'on va avoir un débat sur
cette question certains disant d'aller
regarder on a fait la preuve du fait que
l'hôpital public ça marche pas donc il
faut le privatiser
je rappellerai juste dans ce débat là
que le site le fameux privé allemand
puisque il est souvent invoquée
aujourd'hui le secteur sanitaire privé
allemand cdu fonds privés ce sont des
epic équivalent d epic chez nous les
établissements en fait sous tutelle de
l'état à but non lucratif
donc si c'est ça qu'on appelle le privé
j'y suis très favorable ça n'a rien à
voir avec les cliniques privées qui
n'existe pas donc l'amour la vie à cet
enjeu là puis un troisième aspect qui
est disons paradoxalement de savoir
quelle mouche a piqué ce que j'entendais
des amis médecins qui travaillent dans
le domaine c'est que la france a disons
d'une certaine manière depuis plusieurs
années pris un parti extrêmement centré
autour de l'hôpital
donc dès que vous couper un doigt vous
allez à l'hôpital
vous faites un petit bobo vous allez à
l'hôpital alors ce n'est absolument pas
nécessaire de sorte qu'il y a on a
délogé le médecin généraliste de sa
position qui devrait être sa position
centrale dans le système sanitaire
français
ces médecins généralistes qui doit être
le premier interlocuteur du n'importe
quel citoyen une pathologie et qui doit
ensuite orientée intelligemment le
patient ou de mémoire les statistiques
c'est que il ya sur sur 100 français qui
ont une qui souffre d'une pathologie
vous en avez de 25 ans qui ne se soigne
pas 20 à 25 qui cherchent des solutions
du type rebouteux et autres qui sortent
domaine médical classique
vous avez 50 qui vont dans le domaine
médical classique sur ces 50 vous en
avez moins de dix qui ont besoin d'aller
à l'hôpital est donc en fait c'est le
boulot du médecin généraliste quand il
faut évidemment revaloriser la
profession est qu'il faut redistribuer
sur le territoire français les normands
joueurs
le territoire c'est par exemple de dire
à tout médecin généraliste en échange
d'une revalorisation du métier bien
pendant les dix premières années de
votre carrière vous n'allez pas choisir
votre lieu de l'impression et vous irez
par exemple dans la creuse qui est
devenue un désert médical français
de la même manière qu'on le fait pour
les chercheurs enseignants comme vous
savez j'ai commencé ma carrière de
chercheur au cnrs à strasbourg
parce que le scénariste en avait décidé
ainsi et c'est très bien voilà donc la
vie et tous ces éléments là font que
dans le système sanitaire français est à
la peine pour répondre à l'enjeu de la
pandémie je pense qu'il ya deuxième est
un sou sujet là dedans mais qui est
massif qui est celui des défaillances de
la décentralisation en france nous avons
produit un institut rousseau une note la
dgt sur laquelle je ne peux que vous
renvoyer qui est très bonne
je crois que ce qu'il faut skier devant
domicile c'est de repenser la
décentralisation à la française
puisque vous l'avez vous l'avez remarqué
vous même certainement une partie du
cafouillage de notre administration
autour de la question n'est des tests
puisque par exemple laboratoires
vétérinaires ont déclaré très tôt qu'ils
étaient capables qu'il était en mesure
de procéder à des tests et puis on a
perdu notre quatre jours et trois
semaines avant que lors une d'autoriser
de multiples autorisations
administratives leur soit donnée de
procéder à ces textes ce qui compte tenu
du bilan en termes de morts chaque jour
était évidemment catastrophique donc là
aussi il ya une vrai enjeu de repenser
la décentralisation à la française de
manière si on donne des compétences à
organes décentralisés lui donner les
moyens d'assumer ses compétences et la
responsabilité sinon on est dans un jeu
de déresponsabilisation avec un don de
compétences sans moyens et donc on
arrive ostroff qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui je crois la question
suivante c'est ceci la dalle
relocalisation pourrait nous conduire à
des nationalisations stratégique c'est
très possible
je pense que si vous voulez que je crois
un petit peu de hauteur parce que sinon
on est obligé de discuter c'est un
secteur mais je pense qu'il ya un enjeu
colossal à comprendre que même du point
de vue de l'analyse économique à
plusieurs cadeaux qu'on appelle
l'économie néoclassique la plus
favorable à dix on a certes un
néolibéralisme égaliser
tous secteurs industriels qui a des
rendements croissants par exemple qui a
un coût fixe donc pour lequel il produit
rien puis certaines fonctions de
production ne peut pas être privatisée
en vérité ce qui fait que et dans les
années 50 on avait des grands
économistes comme marcel boiteux dont le
nom vous dit peut-être quelque chose qui
ont réfléchi là dessus on dit voilà il
ya un certain nombre de secteurs
industriels sur lesquels on peut pas
juste les privatiser ça n'a aucun sens y
compris du point de vue de la
rationalité économique la plus
élémentaire
je vous mets au défi de me trouver un
secteur industriel qui n'a pas de coût
fixe donc donc je crois qu'il ya un vrai
si vous voulez il ya une idéologisation
de la privatisation du monde et en
particulier l'industrie qui est
extrêmement néfaste parce que il ya
toute une série de l'industrie qui
peuvent pas fonctionner comme des
industries privées tout simplement parce
qu'ils aient les continents des coûts
fixes qui rendent le business model pour
parler de manière un peu voilà en
anglais une fois de plus ce qui rend le
business model intenable
ce qui fait que de mon point de vue
depuis une quarantaine d'années ce qu'on
a fait c'est qu'on a chargé l'état
implicitement de payer le coût fixe pour
permettre au secteur privé de bénéficier
des marges sur la partie non couche x la
fonction de production du secteur
industriel et on a transformé l'état on
est une espèce d'assureurs général du
secteur privé qui à chaque fois qu'il va
mal se fait renflouées par l'état c'est
le fameux thème de la socialisation des
pertes et la privatisation prochaine
donc je crois qu'il ya une vraie
réflexion avoir de manière que l'état
aujourd'hui puis serait entrer dans un
dialogue et de collaboration avec le
secteur privé
ça veut pas dire transformer l'économie
française dans une union soviétique pas
du tout ça veut dire trouver des
méthodes de collaboration du type dia et
de manière que on est un récepteur
industriels dont on prenne en charge
collectivement et y compris entreprise
elle-même concernée et ses actionnaires
quand il y en a le coût des coûts fixes
donc ça peut passer par des
nationalisations ça peut passer à la
mise en place d' établissements à but
non lucratif sous tutelle de l'état
alors là qu'elle était la question
suivante oui comment est-ce que les
propositions sont perçues par le
gouvernement je vous avoue que j'en sais
rien je ne sais pas très précisément
ce que je sais c'est que ces
propositions sont lu très attentivement
ça j'en ai la preuve est ce qu elle doit
être mise en oeuvre au jour
d'aujourd'hui je le souhaite évidemment
la perception d'un accroissement du
d'endettement public par le grand public
par nos citoyens mon point de vue c'est
que la casse sociale va être tellement
phénoménal dans les mois et les années
qui viennent que la question du chômage
va devenir la hantise primordial des
citoyens français et que toute
proposition qui permettra de résoudre le
problème du chômage même si elle se
concrétise par un accroissement des deux
public sera accueilli dans la liesse à
l'ehpad concitoyens français si on a 25
% de chômage à la fin de l'année c'est
vraiment ça devient un enjeu social
politique majeur pour tout le monde
existentielle donc je suis pas sûr du
tout que nonobstant le si vous voulez le
matraquage médiatique autour de l' des
publics dont je rappelle que c'est pas
du tout le problème numéro 1 dans
l'économie française
je suis pas sûr du tout qu'il y ait une
levée de boucliers des citoyens français
sur le thème l'on veut bien rester au
chômage parce que on veut pas monter la
des publics j'y crois c'est ma question
du temps de travail j'ai pas très bien
entendu qui était la question si c est
ce que c'est une bonne idée d'augmenter
d'un travail dans les ponts sinon c'est
le meilleur moyen d'avoir plus du
chômage je sais bien que c'est
l'obsession du medef dont je rappelle
aussi que la la tendance de très long
terme sur deux siècles
en dépit en fait à cause grâce aux
progrès techniques c'est la réduction du
travail
la vie est à la réduction du temps de
travail je pense qu'en plus avec
l'explosion du chômage que nous allons
en vain devant nous il faudrait se poser
la question d'un passage même à 32 eur
je sais bien que la question que le
passage à 35 heures c'est fait dans les
conditions qui n'est pas optimal pour le
certain nombre de nos secteurs
ce qu'il faut ce à quoi il faut
réfléchir c'est la manière dont on passe
à 35 heures ou à 32 mais sur la question
de savoir s'il faut augmenter le temps
de travail mais le portier clermont dont
je vois aucun argument en faveur de
cette idée là pour le couple
franco-allemand je suis bien d'accord
que ce couple va avoir des grandes
difficultés à vendre des querelles de
ménage très forte
je voudrais simplement attirer votre
attention sur le fait que je sais qu'il
ya un plan de sortie de la zone euro par
les pays du nord qui n'a aucun caractère
officiel
donc je le dis mais je ne peux pas vous
dire d'où j'ai cette information les
banques centrales d'allemagne autriche
pays bas finlande se sont coordonnés il
ya quelques années il ya 5 6 ans pour
mettre en place un plan de sortie et la
construction d'un d'une zone euro nord
qui est en fait une zone à ils ont
marqué tendue pour le cas où ça chauffe
rétro au sein de la zone euro avec les
pays du sud et la question m'a été posée
de savoir ce que devrait faire la france
si un tel plan de sortie a été activée
par les pays du lin ma réponse à moi
s'est il faudrait surtout pas y aller il
faudrait dans ce cas là prendre la tête
une zone euro sud
plutôt que de venir les grecs de la zone
1 je suis pas sûr que ce soit la réponse
privilégiée par les administrations
publiques françaises qui auraient pu de
manière non officielle être consulté sur
ce sujet mais je pense que c'est aussi
dans ce terminal se pose la question du
couple franco allemand s'est dit qu'il
faut pas du tout être naïf et il faut
être conscient du fait que nos voisins
allemands sont prêts à mettre fin en
fait au projet fédérateur orgue ainsi
leurs intérêts immédiats étaient trop
menacés par le crise avec les pays du
sud pour tout dire une note positive
cette question je pense en même temps
quand même qu'il ya plein de projets
nous pourrions lancer conjointement
entre la france et l'allemagne
et je reviens sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
l'allemagne elle même problème que nous
l a parc immobilier extrêmement riche
qui souffrent également d'être constitué
en grande partie des passoires
thermiques
elle a aussi besoin de procéder à la
rénovation thermique de son bâti public
on pourrait très bien engagé un dialogue
avec nos voisins et amis allemands sur
le thème on lance la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments en particulier
du bâti public conjointement en
allemagne et en france
ça c'est des projets très concrets sur
lesquels me semble-t-il on peut redonner
la vitalité au couple franco allemand
je partage avec vous les préoccupations
de du changement climatique et de la
priorité que nous devons garder de sur
la baisse des gaz à effet de serre et
sur la préoccupation de la baisse de la
biodiversité qui brille questionne comme
il a été question totale
de la place de la nature dans notre
société alors au sujet des rénovations
thermiques donc d'après ce que j'ai
compris il s'agirait de dents fête du
travail
donner à des à des jeunes qui se dit se
formeraient pendant plusieurs dizaines
d'années c'est ça alors vous me direz si
c'est exact
après sur la mobilité verte moi je
trouve que d'une manière générale on ne
naît pas assez l'accent sur les
mobilités qu'on appelle douce maintenant
qu'ils sont des mobilités qui ne
nécessite aucune énergie le vélo et la
marche et malheureusement je trouve que
ce sont les grèves que c'est la pandémie
qui ont fait que les citoyens d'eux
mêmes se sont tournés vers ces mobilités
là alors qu'on pourrait et développé
bien plus
ensuite concernant la l'union européenne
dont on dit que c'est le meilleur
endroit au monde parce qu'il est solide
des mains début parce que c'est il ya
une solidité démocratique et que l'union
européenne inspire la confiance est ce
que est ce que vous voyez enfin vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de cette
europe du sud europe du nord est et moi
une question m'est venue est ce qu'il
nous faudrait nous tourner davantage
vers le bassin méditerranéen donc ça
c'est juste une question qui a été qui
m'est venue alors que vous parliez de
7,2 cette scission et éventuellement
alors après j'avais une autre question
sur la dette privée parce que vous avez
parlé à la dette privée et donc moi j'ai
découvert ça que la dette privée était
bien plus important quelle est sa
répartition ménages entreprises
je suis tu je suis très étonné parce que
je suis c'est vrai qu'on parle souvent
de la dette de l'état et donc voilà si
vous pouviez juste nous en dire deux ou
trois mots après sur les vents
contraires qu'on pourrait connaître
parce que je partage avec vous tous tout
au tout ce que vous avez dit sur ce
qu'il nous faudrait faire pour changer
la société
mais il ya des forces énormes qui sont à
l'oeuvre
alors papa dans l'ombre d'ailleurs je
vais parler d'une entreprise globale
très puissante commence par aaa et qui a
vu bien évidemment à ses gains bondir
pendant
cette pandémie et qui même à des visées
d'après ce que j'ai pu découvrir hier
soir dans une émission des visées sur la
santé et prendrez vous avez parlé de la
santé comme bien commun et de et d'avoir
des visées pour prendre en charge ce
domaine là donc qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
et puis j'avais une dernière question
sur les taxes et sur les externalités
qui nous faudrait prendre en compte pour
et puis est encore une question pardon
sur la formation parce que vous vous
vous avez mis en avant qu'il nous
faudrait former des jeunes
mais pour donner du sens à tout cela il
nous faut bien évidemment pas considérer
enfin il faut pas considérer que pour
donner du sens aux jeunes pour qu'ils se
lancent dans ces formations que soit mis
l'accent davantage dans l'éducation sur
sur ces sujets comme les biens communs
comme le le le rôle qui pourrait jouer
dans la société et ce qui n'est pas fait
pour l'instant
donc voilà sept jeux il ya peut-être
beaucoup de questions mais jour merci
davance merci beaucoup aux imprévus que
j'ai donnée par le monsieur gilles et
merci monsieur le président
toutes les aides aujourd'hui dans
l'idéal devrait être éco conditionnalité
bien sûr il faudrait travailler sur le
périmètre de ces éco conditionnalité
bien au delà de de l'empreinte carbone
quelle est votre analyse sur ce sujet
quelles propositions factuel serait-il
possible de mettre en oeuvre dès
aujourd'hui puisque on voit bien que le
soutien à l'économie sociale et je
l'espère culturel est conditionnée
aujourd'hui sur des aides publiques qui
pourraient être fléché donc sur ces
sujets là vous confronter par ailleurs
les approche macroéconomique au local et
aux territoires avaient pu l'évoquer
mais comment repenser vous justement les
solidarités et que danic et
l'environnemental dans une nouvelle
approche notamment du
ils européen dans ces notions de
solidarité de gouvernance territoriale
peuvent jouer à un rôle important par
rapport à la mise en oeuvre de nouvelles
politiques publiques a été évoquée par
exemple l'autonomie alimentaire mais pas
uniquement on voit bien que des schémas
territoriaux de développement des
énergies renouvelables 106 porter
aujourd'hui le développement d'activités
intégrée à l'échelle des territoires ce
ne sont que quelques exemples dont
quelle est votre vision sur ces
subsidiarité
merci monsieur gilles et on termine
cette série de questions et que monsieur
ronan dantec
oui merci monsieur le président bonjour
à tous ma question va peut compléter
celle de mon collègue au hall gad si on
le fait que j'ai quand même le sentiment
que la kz europe afrique comme réponse à
la crise est un des grands absents du
débat public aujourd'hui et on parle
assez peu de l'afrique alors que si on
parle autonomie finalement c'est
probablement sur un axe europe afrique
qu'on atteint l'autonomie alimentaire et
pas uniquement dans la relocalisation
donc je ma question est à ce niveau-là
de savoir comment aujourd'hui on
renforce cet axe repas fric
l'afrique est probablement aujourd'hui
le continent qui souffrent le plus de
cette crise même si le comique du mois
en afrique ont différentes raisons
notamment démographiques
est-ce que la planche à billets
européenne quel que soit le pardon le
mécanisme utilisé
on l'utilisé aussi pour l'afrique n'est
peut-être pas pour impayés les
remboursements chinois qui s'inquiètent
quand même beaucoup aujourd'hui à ce
niveau là de ce qu'ils ont investi en
afrique
je pense que je pense qu'on n'a pas pris
la mesure de la gravité de la situation
en afrique
j'ai des rapports de la tanzanie hier ce
bien commun ce patrimoine de l'humanité
par exemple qu'est la grande faune
africaine pourrait ne pas survivre
plusieurs mois la crise touristique et
est aujourd'hui le modèle principal de
la de la conservation de la biodiversité
en afrique pour prendre que cet exemple
y en a bien d'autres
et en complément de cette question sur
l'axé europe afrique
on est dans un monde inde économie
mondialisée bien sûr est ce que les
américains et les chinois vont accepter
par exemple une taxe carbone aux
frontières alors que et une grosse
défaite européenne il ya quelques années
sur le ts concernant l'aviation un déjà
où les chinois avaient dit non et quand
on a quand même en face de nous des
puissances économiques qui ont aussi les
moyens de dire non à une partie de nos
stratégies donc comme angad giro vous
voyez cette guerre économique qui est
derrière finalement une partie des
réponses que l'europe serait prête
peut-être adopter pour sortir de cette
crise merci beaucoup et bien monsieur j
ose aller pour répondre à cette dernière
série de questions merci beaucoup et je
vais être obligée de faire très rapide
parce que je dois vous quitter dans deux
minutes dont vous pardonnerez si je suis
un peu lapidaire le la crise est
mondiale
un élan qui les appellent à nouveau
brito douce oui tout à fait je crois
qu'il faut prendre conscience du fait
que c'est la première fois depuis 1945
que nous avons une telle paralysie des
institutions onusiennes avec un conseil
de sécurité qui est incapable jusqu'à
présent de se réunir et de prendre une
décision collective
donc c'est de mon point de vue
extrêmement préoccupante que s'assigne
c'est l'effondrement progressif ça date
pas d'aujourd'hui du mil d'être
multilatéralisme onusien tel qu'on
l'avait construit en 45 et qui trop
longtemps en fait à masquer le
leadership américain
donc il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui
notamment du fait de l'occupant actuel
de la maison blanche il ya plus de
leadership américain et les
nations-unies derrière ça s'effondre et
les montres le contre que le roi est nu
donc là il ya un énorme enjeu de
reconstruction d'un multilatéralisme
mondiale dans un contexte où est donc ça
fait un lien avec une question de la
guerre à laquelle était une religion un
instant dans un contexte où les
relations avec la chine sont qu'on
puisse en dire c'est extrêmement
compliqué donc
donc moi qui suis très favorable avec
par exemple la mise en place
enfin du nu si on rêve une minute du
planking 55 pour gérer les transactions
internationales qui étaient beaucoup
plus intelligent que ce qui avait été ce
qui a été mis en place
avec les accords de bretton-woods donc
on aurait déjà pu faire beaucoup mieux à
l'époque il est encore temps de faire
et disons une réforme de refonte
complète du de l'agenda de loi nc qui
est plus du tout simplement de veiller à
l'abolition de toutes les frontières
pour favoriser le niveau de change dont
j'ai pas de problème à l'éthique du fait
que ce soit bien fait pour tout le monde
mais la mise en place au contraire de
d'accords multilatéraux certainement pas
bilatéraux mis d'accords multilatéraux
dans une coopération qui aujourd'hui
absolument indispensable donc vous êtes
le principe directeur 1 pour nous c'est
que on ne peut pas venir à bout d'une
pandémie comme celle du co lead sans une
coopération de tous les pays de la
planète
nous avons nous allons éradiquer la
variole dans les années 70 uniquement à
28 moment où tous les pays sans
exception ont procédé les campagnes de
vaccination nous ont permis de de
supprimer la période il en ira de même
pour le virus du coc vie de 19,6 un pays
continuent de laisser les russes
proliférer le virus mute rares viendra
chez nous il deviendra une pandémie
saisonnière et nous aurons des horreurs
comme ce que nous avons aujourd'hui tous
les ans donc avec des mutations
éventuellement suffisamment forte pour
qu'il fasse refaire nous il fallait
refaire un nouveau vaccin chez les
conditions et qui seront certainement
extrêmement dégradée donc
donc voila mon avis si vous voulez la
grande tension les défi colossal qui est
devant nous du point de vue
international c'est à la fois de
réapprendre une vraie coopération
internationale que nous avons
relativement négligées au point d'une
année pour laisser se réinstaller des
rapports de force entre la chine la
russie les états-unis droite donc
réapprendre une certaine forme de
coopération qui est indispensable dans
l'intérêt de tous parce que même la
russie est capable de comprendre que
c'est dans son intérêt
parce que comme vous savez elle
souffrait également beaucoup du camp est
un virus dans un contexte où il faut
aussi relocaliser une partie de notre
industrie donc ça de manière au premier
abord on se dit mais c'est complètement
contradictoire on fait ça l'est pas je
crois qu'il faut comprendre que là nous
avons réduit la mondialisation conduit à
la simple globalisation marchande
or il serait du passé jeudi ont pu très
bien réguler les transactions de biens
et de services et les transactions de
capital tout en réorganisant une
coopération politique mais en
réapprenant à ce permis au niveau
international est-ce que ça passe par
une remise de revitalisation des nations
unies c'est l'option est ce qu'on peut
faire aujourd'hui grandes nouvelles
déclarations du type déclaration de
philadelphie 1144 pour redire la
question sanitaire à la question
écologique la question sociale c'est la
clé la paix dans le monde
j'espère qu'il faut réunir les
conditions géopolitiques très concrètes
que ce site puisse se faire et au jour
d'aujourd'hui les conseils de sécurité
n'arrivent même pas à faire la moindre
déclaration commune alors la question
suivante et je n'arrive plus à me relire
donc je suis désolé je vais être obligé
de la soutenir l'aide au développement
qu'elle rôle peut-être jouer je vais en
parler c'est tout à l'heure avec la
question de l'afrique donc je passe
immédiatement la question d'après qui
était la formation professionnelle dans
le bâti c'est pas d'y lancer de trois
ans de formation cousine et donc c'est
tout à fait abordables tout de suite
et de fait mais je pense que c'est ça
que vous faisiez allusion les jeunes que
je rencontre aujourd'hui n'ont pas du
tout envie de faire nos métiers donc
leur proposer des formations
professionnelles ou d'humains sa
rencontrera un succès certain du côté
des jeunes
évidemment ça va de pair avec une
refonte des programmes scolaires chez
nous c'est une question qui lui était
posée
je sais qu'il ya un livre blanc qui est
actuellement en préparation pour la
ministre avec vidal sur cette question
j'ai été interrogé dans le cadre d'un
simple oubli commission sur celle sur
cet aspect moi je suis très favorable à
ce qu'on repense la totalité du
programme les bannières qu' on puisse
enseigner de la physique en tenant en
compte en prenant en compte les enjeux
de la transition écologique et qu'on
puisse aussi enseigné la littérature en
prenons en compte il est question il ya
aujourd'hui une littérature absolument
foisonnant et très intéressante qui va
bien au delà de l'apocalypse et de la
fin du monde sur ce que c'est qu'une
société décarbonés et ce serait on
serait très inspiré mon avis de de
favoriser l'exposition de nos enfants
asthmatiques
mais donc c'est à dire un enjeu de
réécriture en fait de programmes et de
nos manières de faire qui est déjà en
cours il ya beaucoup d'écoles primaires
dans lesquelles la cour d'école ont fait
du jardinage en fait la première culture
sensibiliser nos enfants à ces questions
deux instituteurs sens il faut juste à
mon âge il ne généralisez la cnlc au
niveau national donc on bourrine c'est à
dire qu'il ya peut-être un problème je
ne m'attendais plus si on bouge on vous
entend très bien le problème
micro allumé et on entendrait des bruits
de fond donc je demande à mes collègues
de vérifier la norme micro sur les
mobilités douces je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous on n'est pas assez
l'accent là dessus et vous avez vu et
c'est très heureux qu'un certain nombre
de municipalités ont décidé d'accroître
la le kilométrage des voies cyclables à
la faveur de la pandémie je pense une
très bonne idée il faut continuer mais
évidemment j'aimerais juste dire un mot
là-dessus je suis très favorable aux
vélos moi même je fais du vélo et je
suis végétarien au passage mais je
voudrais juste dire un mot là-dessus
c'est que des calques et qu'on a fait
avec des ingénieurs de cap 4 montre que
si vous faites des efforts à titre
individuel il ya condition d'être un
franciscain extrêmement austère j'ai mis
ça avec toute l'amitié nécessaire plus
grand soutien
vous ne pouvez réduire votre empreinte
carbone c'est un une mesure parmi
d'autres en phase d'étude qui a c'est
l'essentiel vous pouvez réduire votre
empreinte carbone que de 30% grand
maximum si les génériques lire et 70%
qui dépend pas d'individus et donc ceci
pour signaler le fait que évidemment on
doit encourager chacun chacune et chacun
à prendre le vélo de plus plus prendre
l'avion mais en fait
bon c'est un aspect finalement minorité
du promu ça le palais il faut pas le
faire donc les petits gestes du
quotidien sont indispensables mais mais
l'enjeu est encore beaucoup plus vaste
salle mobilis forcément l'état mais vous
le savez c'est lui c'est bien connu sur
l'union européenne
didier houi alors est ce que l'union
européenne c'est vraiment le havre que
tout le monde envie c'est je suis très
heureux de vous poser cette question
parce que c'est c'est pas moi c'est pas
mon expérience
beaucoup de pays du sud ont très bien
payés que l'union européenne est le
champion du néo libéralisme le plus
cynique en tant qu'union européenne pas
les étains pas la france mais l'union
européenne donc je vous donne un exemple
sur le débat qui a été relancée sur la
question du devoir de vigilance
vigilance qui interdit aux
multinationales de haut font violer
allègrement les lois ils ont le travail
des règles du travail décentes quelle
sont édictées par l'office international
du travail auprès de leurs sous
traitants de manière que la
multinationale elle même elle se donne
et des diplômes de vertu mais en fait
c'est sous traitants font le sale boulot
est ce que le régime est en employés
pour faire une vraie la plaza en 2013
donc il ya eu comme vous le savez
différents dans des négociations pour
mettre en place une loi au niveau
international sur l'équivalent de ce que
nous appelons nous en france la loi sont
des mois de silence et la russie a voté
pour les états unis a voté tôt la chine
avait tout d'une union européenne a voté
contre et donc d'avancer assez perçu
immédiatement à les pays du sud comme
une manière de signifier de l'union
européenne et on est tout à fait
confortable avec le fait que les droits
de l'homme soient bafoués tous les jours
dans les sous traitants des
multinationales au passage la france et
a retenu ce qui est un peu mieux mais
pas tout à fait satisfaisant le segment
conclusions sur la dette privée donc les
chiffres c'est 70 % des ménages 60% les
entreprises sur un total de 130 % qui va
forcément évoluer dans les mois qui
viennent à cause de la pandémie
la raison elle est très simple en fait
c'est que dans une économie où il avait
alors les ménages bon pour dire les
choses de manière très très mal si emma
explosion de la dette des ménages c'est
le creusement des inégalités
plus vous avez des inégalités plus les
ménages modestes sont obligés de
s'endetter pour maintenir leur niveau de
vie donc le mécanisme j'ai pu les les
papilles là dessus il est
malheureusement bien connu et bien bien
illustré aujourd'hui publiquement
du côté des ménages c'est l'insuffisance
de la saison du dynamisme économique
français à partir du moment où vous
entrez dans une nation où décès sur une
pente déflationniste vous avez une
absence de revenus
du côté des entreprises qui fait que le
meilleur moyen le seul moyen pour elle
de continuer en activité c'est ça le
sens et l avantage
la prise de pouvoir par les gars femmes
évidemment il faut lutter contre ça je
suis néanmoins favorable
donc ça suppose de faire son deuil les
l'idée que le libre échange c'est la
panacée l'horizon ultime d'une
civilisation aujourd'hui l'éducation
j'en ai parlé la conditionnalité des
aides
il reste deux minutes donc je vais aller
à l'essentiel je pense qu'on pourrait
très bien décider de conditionnalité
conditionné par exemple d'appel d'offres
public inde et de la vertu écologique
c'est ça n'est pas autorisé par des
institutions européennes aujourd'hui
mais je pense qu'il faut on est après
débat sur cette question il n'y a aucune
raison que l'argent public aujourd'hui
soit à candé à des candidats aux appels
d'offres qui ne serait pas bien tu es du
point de vue du point de vue écologique
la subsidiarité est bien évidemment j'y
suis très favorable avec c'est un vieux
concepts liés
c'est un vieux concept théologique en
fait qui est un menteur au moyen âge
à mon avis ils acheminent heureusement
je ne suis plus le temps d'entraînement
détail il faut l'articuler à leur jeu
que j'ai décrit vais tout à l'heure sur
la décentralisation et sur la question
de savoir comment nous pourrons repenser
la vie sans coordination en france sur
l'axé europe afrique je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous que c'est un enjeu
colossal
l'afd a donc l' agence française de
développement a pris fait résolument
cette option il ya plusieurs années de
dire en fait notre terrain de jeu celle
axe vertical longitudinale europe
afrique qui fait en fait qui marche d'un
seul tenant
comment est-ce qu'on peut avancer
davantage dans cette direction mais une
première option qui a été poussé par
l'actuel gouvernement c'est quand même
de nouveau l'annulation des dettes
évidemment ça fait très peur en chine ce
serait aussi un moyen de remettre
replacer le débat de la dette publique
africaine dans le club de paris qui
al'avantage d'être à paris vous savez
qu'il ya un petit enjeu là dessus
puisque la chine en fait en train
d'essayer en réalité de vider le club de
paris son contenu et de rapatrier
c'est ce soulier une négociation en
chine ce qui à mon avis une très bonne
idée pour l'afrique donc voilà une bonne
manière de procéder c'est déjà tout de
suite d'annuler partie de l'année
publique africaine pour permettre aux
états de faire face aux conséquences du
confinement il pas que vous l'avez
rappelé nous mêmes profits conséquents
du virus qui fait très peu de morts en
afrique subsaharienne
à cause l'extraordinaire jeunesse de nos
populations africaines à la moyenne
d'âge ses 20 ans donc c'est très peu de
bord lié au virus
il y en a beaucoup plus de morts liés
aux tentatives de confinement qui ont
été mises en place dans la confusion la
plus totale sur le continent africain
la taxe carbone et je vais m'arrêter là
donc quand vous savez j'y suis favorable
est ce que les états unis pourraient s'y
résoudre ça dépend très certainement en
particulier en partie de l'état de
l'élection présidentielle à la fin de
cette année si ce résultat nous est
favorable
j'ai une bonne espoir que la nouvelle
majorité qui pourrait s'installer à la
maison blanche
ils soient favorables et qu'on mette fin
ils ont aux errements pour dire les
choses menu extrêmement poli de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui à la maison blanche
pour le reste je rappelle que l'union
européenne reste la première puissance
économique sur cette planète et que l'on
a des vrais atouts au faire valoir notre
point de vue ce qui est tragique c'est
que nous n'arrivions pas à parler d'une
seule voix et que surtout sujet et y ait
des discordances entre eux
nous sommes bien loin d'un côté les
flamands les italiens les français
si vous avez vu en parler d'une seule
voix nous aurions un poids politique à
la mesure de notre poids économique
aujourd'hui sur la planète